um and i think you're you're gonna be uh
loud enough
uh how's my hair perfect you need a hair
and makeup girl you don't have one we
don't have one we can't afford that
uh-huh
you know
i've heard that [ __ ] before we're doing
we actually could but you know i mean
when you go over what you pay i know i
know it's too much i know i know and and
you just get used to when you're really
bootstrapping yeah you get used to not
[ __ ] wasting [ __ ] money that's the
whole thing and i i know so many people
who actually spend more money to feel
more legitimate yeah oh yeah that's
called in the startup industry that's
called playing house um and it's
everyone including us does it with the
first money they get right um so and
they go let me feel let's feel more
legitimate yeah because we're spending
the money exactly all right let's get
this we're in we're in we're in we don't
tell you when we're in oh we don't we
just go in excellent actually yeah so
i can so i can tell my acid story i'd
love to hear it all right let's hear
curtis yarvin is with us google
brilliant that's a brilliant trick um
and um all right so um
you know uh tim wanted me to uh humanize
myself a little bit yeah because with
drugs it's good to be human um and so
one of the best ways um you know to
humanize yourself besides wearing an
authentic shay shirt this is actually
made in cuba by the way it was given to
me by my friend sam frank who visited
that country so i love that i can't
prove it but i believe you it is
absolutely true amazing you can inspect
the label later but um
anyway so um um
acid so i guess my acid story is from
1997. do you remember where were you in
1997 i was 12 but also starting to do my
first acid uh drop was 13. wow that's
very early so so i was i was um just to
set the stage um i was precocious in a
number of things and um i actually
skipped three grades before high school
i grew up as a foreign service brat and
when between when i was 10 and 11
um i was three grades ahead in the
english school nicosia cyprus which was
a little british public school where we
wore uniforms and had houses just like
in harry potter i love that um and um um
should i look at the camera no okay okay
um
and um
then my parents as diplomats do move
back to washington
and i was sent to wilde lake high school
in columbia maryland um a distant suburb
of dc as a 12-year-old sophomore so um
basically i've you know i've just so you
were a 12 year old a 12 year old
sophomore
in a public school
in maryland did the kids think that was
cool or did they hate you well i think
the thing is that would you know for
when that's an excellent question and i
think that basically
you know um that's in my head i'm like
which movie is exactly which movie is it
right and so you know when you look back
at that you you basically you know
if you're in that role kids and you know
i hope young people aren't watching this
because we're about to talk about drugs
but um the um worse
and worse politics yeah yeah yeah that's
just the segue right you know um um you
know nobody really cares about acid but
you know what we'll get into after that
you know that's the real trip yeah it's
not dmt either right right you know but
um
in any case um it really depends on the
behavior of the kid and how he sort of
behaves in the context of the people
around him um if he's just like really
sweet and funny it's one kind of movie
but if he's a little arrogant [ __ ]
it's going to be the other and which one
were you it was the other okay
so so
yeah
in any case um
you know that led me going to college i
went to johns hopkins because that's
where they had um cty which now since
this summer will be known as the fire
festival of nerd camps but we won't get
into that catastrophe
when you when you're a young
uh person and you're going to learn and
you get like good test scores they do
like advanced you know you'll sit you'll
do like algebra in like a week and a
half by sitting and doing algebra all
day for like six hours by yourself by
your [ __ ] self right so this is this
is like you know this is like
intellectual like [ __ ] boot camp uh
my daughter was supposed to go to it but
it got canceled two days before the
event this year thank you johns hopkins
anyway so i went to johns hopkins as a
freshman because it was there um you
know no respect to johns hopkins but um
it sucked so i transferred to brown so i
graduated from brown
in 92
and then i went to grad school in
computer science at berkeley
and i lasted for about
a year and a half at berkeley before i
decided that
academia sucks even in computer science
and it's like elsewhere um it was just a
bad run of systems professors at
berkeley too so anyway i was like i've
got to drop out and like seek my fortune
in the new multimedia boom the
multimedia bubble of the early 90s which
cd-roms 500 channels like you know you
experienced this as retro but for me
it was real right um and i lived it
right you know in any case basically i
got a job in that bubble
and um and then i also basically got
into the early internet so the early
internet in its capacity
which is amazing because you talk about
it was like decentralized it was a
decentralized social network it actually
worked it had no central government it
was not censored it [ __ ] worked it
was called usenet
and you know let me you know we're gonna
get you know i know everyone wants to
get to the acid but let's talk about
using it for a second yeah please um so
um um
usenet was actually it was a
decentralized social network
that worked it was utterly amazing
it was like if reddit was decentralized
and had an ontology which means like an
actual map of its content rather than
like and it had like a democratic
governance structure it was republic it
was not a dictatorship like right
and it was utterly amazing and here was
the problem with using it basically we
were on this thing nobody knew about it
i remember the first time i read about
the internet in the new york times it
was like seeing your cousin in the new
york times in 1988 and it was about a
worm that was on the internet it was
just like wow the new york times is
writing about the internet right so
usenet basically
the reason that usernet worked we all
thought was that because it was a
decentralized social network and the
future
of humanity
that's what we all just naturally
assumed is that we were part
new we knew it right we didn't believe
it we knew it right it turned out that
actually what made usenet special was
that to get on to use that you had to be
a college student or work at a tech
company
interesting and so you didn't it was it
was it was um yes right it wasn't
everybody it wasn't everybody right it
was basically you know it had it had a
quality filter which was a human filter
which was an elitist filter right you
know it's like if you go to a burning
man have you been a burning man i
haven't you haven't i haven't either
yeah you know someone i feel like i want
to go but i'm sober and i feel like
is that you know i i've always talked in
this uh
on the show about like missing something
in life and then not being able to go
back to it yeah like being able to be
like you know you know some very sick
adults wanted to like replicate summer
camp because they had never gone
and you go this is you look at it and
you go this is it it makes me feel
physically ill i don't know if being a
sober guy at burning man
is a good thing or is it am i trying to
recapture something
i really i really you know i couldn't
tell you um i'm a widower my wife had
gone to burning man a couple of times i
never have my and my fiance is a burner
so
basically this gives me you know certain
you know we'll get back we'll get back
to that's the trip yeah i promise but
it's interesting to compare burning man
as a community to use net as a community
because both of them have a sense
that in certain senses they're superior
to everything else in the world right
and in certain senses they are superior
to everything else in the world in other
senses like if you look at for example
the total fertility rate of burners
you're going to find a very low number
right and um and so you know or you know
that sort of a community that exists by
sort of almost that reproduces itself
that lasts over time because burning man
is not super young that sort of
reproduces itself by intake rather than
by fertility right there's something
slightly imperfect about that and both
communities have a barrier to entry and
the barrier to entry so the barrier to
entry is what i was about to talk about
it's basically the barrier to entry you
know that sort of creates a filter you
know i was talking to
you know i'm going to protect his name
an intellectual uh you know who knows
the burning man organizers well uh and i
was asking him steve bannon i'm kidding
no steve steven runs steve's runs never
uh you know but yeah you know steve
actually uh you know but um i'm sorry
you know but um the um
um um talking to the guy burning man
yeah talking to the guy burning man and
i'm like why does burning man have you
know if you go to burning man to me from
what i've heard of burning man not being
a burner not wanting to embarrass myself
but i think that what makes burning man
special is the feeling that everyone at
burning man has
that anyone you meet there will be like
an old friend you haven't met yet right
and you know and that's an incredible
feeling in a community and that's an
attitude right that's an attitude that's
a that's an ethos
you know there's all this public ethos
that sort of comes with you know the 12
principles of burning man one of which
is is radical inclusion everyone is
welcome
is that similar would you say bohemian
grove is the same thing
you know yes bohemian grove has a much
more explicit barrier to entry anyway
i'm talking to this guy you know very
very very intelligent interesting
individual and i'm basically like what
it what is it about burning man that
causes
you know this feeling of togetherness
right and you know he's like well you
know we don't use money you know there's
a number of principles of burning man
you know and i'm like you know well
basically my perspective is the reason
that this is the case is that pretty
much everyone at burning man is like
pretty much everyone else is at burning
man as a person moreover what
accomplishes this is a principle that
you might call radical exclusion which
is that it really sucks to get to
burning man it's really hard to be at
burning man you're basically punishing
yourself you know this [ __ ] playa is
like hell right and you're punishing
yourself to get there it's hard to get a
ticket it's hard to find a camp it's
basically it is as you say essentially
the same thing as bohemian grove it's a
slightly different community actually
bohemian grove i was just hearing
someone who's uh
talking to someone who's i guess he's a
guest at bohemian grove because his
father is a member bohemian grove
basically actually started out as
literally bohemian originally it was
like an artsy fartsy club very much like
burning man and that served a similar
you know kind of community people who
would have found bohemians who would
have found themselves very very welcome
and found like felt really completely
right at burning man
um
and so in both of these cases what's
creating
the um the feeling just this incredible
social feeling of togetherness
is like a policy an effective policy of
radical exclusion right and when this
policy breaks down as it did in the
internet in the event that is known as
eternal september um it's called eternal
september because every year in
september a bunch of clueless newbies a
lot of internet slang like newbie was
invented on usenet um a lot of clueless
internet newbies who were freshmen would
descend and then aol
that sent the little disks in the mail
or
aol basically gave all aol users access
to usenet which was basically
sort of you know as if you let you know
the entire
25 million population of
lagos nigeria into brooklyn right right
and so
what happens to usenet after what
happens to use that is that it simply
becomes unusable without without being
an aristocracy without being elitist
without basically its passive filter
it's just unlivable and um you know what
what precedes its death and this is sort
of only a symptom in a way some people
think this caused it is basically it
started developing binaries news groups
in which people used usenet to trade
like wares and so that got everyone's
you know like the result was that all
isps basically pulled usenet access
anyway it imploded and it died and it
was basically because it was essentially
a high trust network um and you know i
don't know if you know the work of
robert putnam uh you know he's a
sociology at harvard right so you know
he did this famous thing called bowling
alone in which he examined the decline
of high trust social networks
he follows it up with i forget the title
of his it may have just been a paper
because this paper in which he found
that basically the more variety
it is and i'm using that word very
intentionally the more variety there is
in a community the lower trust it is and
so if you have like chinatown where it's
basically all chinese people right
there's a lot of trust you know um you
know and as soon as why is that looked
at today as something that's bad
because variety is a synonym for
diversity okay and
see when i always look at it i i grew up
in long island and one island long
island and my grandparents were from
great neck so yeah
now and that's a great point right so
great neck you have persian restaurants
and a lot of sephardic jews that live
there and in other towns you would have
irish and italian people right and
nobody
there was of course long island was
racist and people made jokes and
whatever but there was no violence right
there was absolutely there were no riots
there's no persian on italian riots it's
like the italians don't take it up with
the persians none of that like the
buddhists
in sri lanka right you know yeah yeah
there was no like you know there was no
west side story happening right so to me
i always go you have different groups of
people that choose to live within some
in-group preference right right and they
they can date other groups they why is
that
why is that a bad thing
i think it depends on whether in certain
cases um
you might sort of develop a function
where you say okay
if you examine the kind of
conventional narrative that for example
everyone
at least pretends to believe on their
college application essays right sort of
a nice randomization because who is the
admissions officer we don't know right
but we're pretty sure of what they
believe right you'll notice that this
person basically that's feeling of
in-groupness what um the great arab
historian even called khaldoon called
asabiya the feeling of you know it's us
against the world there's this old
somali proverb actually a number of
countries claim it you know me me my
country against the world me and my clan
um against my country me and my tribe
against i have that tattooed on my lower
back
all right i'm
and of course it ends with me against my
brother right you know right and and and
uh you know that's a little uh you know
that's a little somali but you know
that's like that's not exclusive to
somalia by many many countries claim
that that proverb in a way so what
you'll notice is for example imagine you
were in a world you know let's take the
like
nascent
persian eye italian is that wrestler i
italian can i say no no italians we
abuse on this show constantly awesome
awesome also actually can i tell you a
joke relating to that absolutely um are
you familiar with the work of garibaldi
slightly like not you know i have been
intimidated and have you ever been to
italy i've never been yet which part
where in italy would you like to go if
you want i'd love to go to rome you'd
love to go to rome that's right well
rome yeah rome is around the middle of
italy yeah so um you know garibaldi of
course uh you know um
well you know you probably that's i
can't really tell the joke if you don't
know the story of garibaldi but in case
you do okay in case you do um there's
something very that they say about
garibaldi and parts of italy um
but only parts of italy uh i think they
say it in rome um which is that
garibaldi didn't unify italy
he divided africa right
so sure so i mean there's italians in
this town anyway anyway so so let's
let's take for example
let's take for example um
suppose you have two groups in a society
you have
um persians and i italians i don't know
any racial slurs for persians but i know
they're there
um do can we what about
what about doon [ __ ]
let's just say persian oh god
our friends persian
[Laughter]
are we still on youtube yeah
thank you
uh you know yeah that's i mean right
frankly i'm not even sure that's
actually funny i'm not even sure that's
accurate but you know uh you know in any
case it's not usually what i think of
when it went right right you know um um
um the i mean rugs
more rugs than dunes i think okay but um
um the um let's not go there anyway
we've got persians and italians and um
let's examine basically
one of the ways we can understand there
is a potential conflict between any two
groups within group status so you know
as the great german uh political
philosopher carl schmidt once said the
essential political distinction is that
between friend and enemy so to a persian
all persians are friends to an italian
all italian italians north or south our
friends okay now within the italian
community it's like the proverb right
but you know the thing is when i
italians think about persians basically
they just you know you know they don't
they don't even think about them right
um you know actually i think it's the
other way right but you know in any case
basically so there's a couple of things
you can say about this first and
foremost basically
one of the questions you can ask about
the narrative
is does the narrative promote asabia
among persians
or i italians are i italians for example
taught in the schools to think you know
all i italians must act together right
ever since the persian attacks in fact
on rome you may recall did you know that
there was a roman emperor that was
captured by the persians
and then you know i forget um later
roman empire he's captured by the
persians and he's basically used as a
footstool for the persian emperor to
mount his [ __ ] horse amazing amazing
and when he dies like his skin is
stuffed with straw and preserved right
you don't didn't last to the this right
a lot a lot of things are going on but
you know but in any case you know so
this is what [ __ ] these [ __ ]
persians are right right you know and so
if you go over to the persians then you
know so you have all these stories and
there's sort of a group litigation it's
like the basically the italians have
this brief against valerian it was
valerian the italians have a grief thank
you jesus christ uh um um the italians
have a brief um against the persians
right they've been victimized by the
persians since the days of valerian who
was just not treated like war crime
right look at that [ __ ] right you know
right a war crime right you know and the
thing is that's like typical
you know frankly that's typical persian
behavior right right you know whereas i
italians of course founded [ __ ]
civilization right you know and so then
you go over to the persian side and you
know do they have a brief against the
italians or does the narrative teach
them to be like you know we persians you
know came down from the hills in the
time of darius you know and like
basically the italians have been calling
us names you know sort of all of this
stuff and like we never set out to
attack rome you know like yes valerian
himself or criminal right right you know
and so what's the narrative there
whereas basically
and the thing is from sort of
a kind of natural pattern of human
history the narrative there that you
would expect that's the narrative you
would expect right and if instead the
narrative among the persians is you know
the persians you know we've been
committing wrongs for many years you
know we founded an empire who do you
think we conquered to find that empire
right who became our slaves again look
at what we did with the jews we did
something with the jews right right no
not good right you know that's in the
bible but it's true right you know and
you're basically like you know like we
persians ourselves
you know we're like modern germans
we have to be accountable for our
actions over the centuries it's like the
thing of two different movies you said
right right so the thing is basically
once you imagine one of these movies you
can imagine sort of the other movie and
then your basic question is like
what you're looking at here sort of in
one case or another
is um
what the um
the great italian political scientist
daitona mosca um who's best accessed in
the machiavellians by james burnham a
book i've been promoting for like 10
years great um great have you read that
i've read that it's [ __ ] awesome the
first like you know like imagine this
like first chapter you're learning
boxing like right in your first chapter
you're like i'm gonna take out muhammad
ali burnham is like i'm gonna take out
dante yeah right
it's an amazing book he's like i'm just
gonna [ __ ] deconstruct your ass dante
yeah right you know and and and amazing
[ __ ] books so mosca has this concept
of the political formula the political
formula is basically something that you
believe
whose practical effect on your behavior
is to cause you to support the
government is to support whatever is the
regime or the powers that yeah so
basically we can assume that within this
narrative where basically
the i italians are all like super like
acibia like i italian pride and the
persians are like yeah we persians we
did it like you know i committed persian
crimes right or my ancestors committed
persian crimes right you know um and so
if you see basically i'm not gonna like
try to translate that into today because
you probably have an iq of over 90 out
there right you know but um um the you
know
both of those things for the communities
in which they are believed will turn out
to be basically political formulas they
will turn out to be right things that
are believed that basically strength
they're also kind of pathologies yeah
they're also kind of pathologies right
so the thing is that basically you know
sort of the song this is a smart episode
folks if you can't handle it really you
know yeah we've done enough we do enough
dumb stuff here yeah
so basically you have these these these
memes these ideas that are political
formulas that basically strengthen the
regime right whatever it is and so you
know sort of the essence of my like i'm
sorry we will get to the acid story no
that's fine no no it's okay
we're close we're close we're close to
the acid story okay so um um in any case
um
we're um these political formulas
um in have you heard of the marketplace
of ideas tim are we in that marketplace
right now are we selling [ __ ] in that
this is bizarre we're in the bazaar you
know you're like the world we're so
[ __ ] this is not the cathedral it's
the best the bizarre
that's a good question hey you know uh
um uh let's get some hits on this
spotify the cathedral that's an
interesting question that is an
interesting thing okay let's let's let's
let's table that one down the road i
don't want to get that deep okay okay i
want to keep this shallow you know for
your i want to it bottom out at like 95
iq okay like matt damon like janitors at
harvard
right you know
so anyway so um
you know in the marketplace of ideas we
entrust a lot of things to that
marketplace
we say for example
of
virology we say hey who should make
decisions about virology and our answer
is the virologist
right how how's that how's that working
out for you yeah right and so you know
the um you know the conclusion is that
basically you know those systems were
put in place to basically take power out
of the hands of
politics and politicians that was the
early progressive movement under tr
woodrow wilson and the thing is when i
say take power out of the hands of
politics and politicians what i really
mean is take power out of the hands of
democracy right so basically we sort of
kept this form of government in name the
way britain is nominally like a monarchy
or something because it has this crown
kardashian you know um but um we moved
it to
this marketplace these specialized
marketplaces of of ideas
in the world of experts
and we said you know what
this world of experts
is a marketplace of ideas
and this is a world in which ideas are
competing with each other and you know
people may be right they may be wrong
there's a lot of biases a lot of sellers
the things that are good and cheap and
efficient are going to beat the things
that suck
we encompass every time we fly on an
airplane i've been on a lot of airplanes
recently we encompass that to a
marketplace of to an actual marketplace
sure the marketplace of ideas is
analogous to that it should work and the
truth will compete fiction and i think
truth overall in these marketplaces does
out compete fiction the problem is that
power also it competes weakness right
and so we have these ideas that are
basically empowering or self-empowering
that basically um
sort of you know
like dominate these markets and become
basically there's totally unaccountable
and there's no power that can remove
them so for example you know one of the
things that so for example just for the
experts right yeah these experts
council on foreign relations are those
the experts those are definitely the
experts international monetary fund are
those the experts sure but here's
another example here's another example
basically
um you know peter dazzak and his friends
yes yes you may have covered that yeah
well i've we haven't covered it but i
know what you're talking about yeah you
know what i'm talking about so the best
place to read about peter dazzak and his
his friends is in all places one of my
favorite magazines
um it's called um vanity fair and for
some reason vanity fair has done some
very good articles lately yes i'm not
sure what happened there maybe they took
some acid i don't know we'll get to the
acid soon um um but they did two really
excellent articles
about
the birth of kovid that were not
you know basically beholden to the
virology industry and i think that
basically probably the previous industry
that it has done as much damage as the
virology industry to human health is
probably the tobacco industry right and
so basically when
you sort of look at what happened in
envirology it's sort of as good a case
against the american system as chernobyl
is against the russian system right the
difference is it killed about a thousand
times as many people right um
maybe ten thousand right a lot more and
and and you know essentially what
happened here is you know there's a
funny way to tell the story about kovid
which is a kid remember i grew up i mean
you were one of the first people yeah on
the internet to say this is going to be
a problem yes yes i was saying i was i
was i started writing a piece in the
middle of january i actually started
investing in covet i bought like deep
out of the money puts wow it was insane
to be betting on kovid because you can't
become like pro coveted you start
talking your book that was really weird
yeah that really biased my coverage but
yeah um um i'll admit that yeah and and
that's sort of in a way that's the same
effect as the effect that corrupts these
these systems so what happened in the
case of here's my narrative of kovid so
when i was a kid i was in the
commonwealth world and like cyprus and
it was very easy to get like british
books one very common form of british
books were these books by gerald durrell
brother of lawrence durrell uh hbo where
someone had the you know the darrells
and corfu had this beautiful you know
why not show that was basically made out
of his wonderful memoirs absolutely
great to read when i was 12. and darrell
was a zoologist and he went around
collecting little fluffy animals from
like imperiled commonwealth countries in
which you know barbarians were at the
gates right it was just the crazy times
like the 50s and 60s
everything is falling apart right and
he's collecting beautiful fluffy animals
for his little zoo back in england and
he does well with us and he does well
with his books he found a zoo in jersey
uh not new jersey but jersey and um he
basically um you know creates this
organization called the wildlife trust
which is dedicated to
you know getting rich old ladies to give
money to go and collect little fluffy
animals sounds like a win
um along comes this guy peter gazzak who
has some like [ __ ] degree from
somewhere but is really a science
administrator and he decides and he
becomes the administrator of the
wildlife trust and he decides that he
can start getting grants bigger grants
better grants by changing the mission of
the wildlife trust slightly to have it
go around instead of collect little
fluffy animals
collect viruses specifically bat
coronaviruses so he turns the wildlife
trust into something called echo health
alliance
if you've heard um the name
which is an organization that basically
kind of gets massive grants and
redistributes them to scientists to
basically find and study bat
coronaviruses
um
and some of this work is done in china
this is not really a thing about chinese
science maybe it's something about how
like sloppy things are in china but like
there's a word um for like i'm going to
butcher this this is this is a what uh
chinese word you were saying
it means
i speak mandarin oh awesome awesome my
daughter speaks mandarin
i was like i was like wow you just fixed
that yeah
mandarin awesome awesome awesome awesome
so so basically so this research into
bat coronaviruses is subtract
subcontracted uh you know which is to
like
biosafety level two you know research
for seeing like the docks of china right
you know
[ __ ] han
right right you know it's not shanghai
right you know and and it's like what
would be the american equivalent of
wuhan um detroit detroit right right
okay we heard that you they were doing
the most important or any kind of
important virus research in detroit we
would be we would be asking more
questions right right right right so
this research
is basically subcontracted to detroit
now two things about this research one
is its justification is to quote predict
the emergence of you know novel
coronaviruses the cause of this research
was the original outbreak of sars
right and in fact one of the people
involved in like virology governance is
a technical advisor to the steven
soderbergh film contagion which is well
worth watching um which is a from the
mid watts i think yes which is um
basically explicitly about a back
coronavirus yes so because this happened
basically bat coronaviruses are a
problem
and because it's a problem yeah so we're
getting
we're popping the stack now so so
getting back to
this problem so okay back coronaviruses
are a problem therefore they're
important therefore you can get grants
to study them you don't have to rely on
little old ladies anymore instead of
collecting animals you're collecting bad
viruses which means you collect bats so
basically the same thing right right
you're getting all these grants to study
bad coronaviruses the more important
um your work is the more money it will
get makes sense we allocate money by
importance yes right the more dangerous
bat coronaviruses are the more money you
will get now back coronaviruses are bad
viruses to operate in humans they have
to mutate
they have to be changed they have to be
mutate either naturally through passive
or they have or artificially
in the lab and we know that was going on
and we know that basically in the course
of like four days the like head
virologists of the world changed their
minds which they'd come into like this
looks like a lab leak too this doesn't
look like a lab like right there will
never be any accountability for these
[ __ ] and and there's no power
that's gonna say hey science you're
[ __ ] and the way in which science is
[ __ ] is like this is a good example
case because basically here is this
problem
of like bat coronaviruses it's a real
problem
no one disputes that
it stars really emerged from animals it
was not a weird soviet experiment that
escaped right so it is possible for this
to be a threat because it is possible
for it to be a threat is a problem
therefore one can get grants to study
this the worse a problem it seems to be
the more grants you're going to get so
you have basically a feedback loop in
the marketplace of ideas in which this
idea basically brings power to that
market
right so if you're basically a bat
coronavirus researcher and you're like
you know what what are we going to do if
we predict and outbreak
right like predicting i predict there
will be an earthquake in the bay area
okay let's build our houses a little bit
stronger right you know what what have
you actually done here like uh was any
of this research useful in solving the
actual outbreak absolutely not the
profit motive in the marketplace of
ideas can corrupt right but it's not
specifically it's sort of when you think
of a profit motive that's not really the
way academics think they think of like
an empire building motive they think of
like my career is more successful if
this is a bigger problem yes you know
and so they basically play pokemon
with
coronaviruses and then they like mutate
their [ __ ] pokemon to make them as
dangerous as possible in like basically
low-rent walmart tier
labs in detroit right and then they're
basically like and you know when you
step back the important thing is when
you when you pull the camera back and
you look at this behavior
okay this is absolutely kind of been
blaming china for this no but we're
letting china off day and we are a fan
of china on this show and we believe in
one china we don't even know what taiwan
is
so incredibly based incredibly but this
isn't a china problem this is a us
problem this is a problem with with the
way we do [ __ ] and we basically said
we're going to take the experts you know
who's going to watch the watchdogs
ancient political question right and
they're like well why don't the experts
watch the watchdogs
excellent answer and then the question
is who watches the experts and they're
like well you know i guess they could
watch themselves right right and when
they watch themselves they do [ __ ] like
this which is every bit as dumb as like
what it was done in [ __ ] chernobyl
where they're like let's turn off the
backup backup backup safety system
that our reactor is safer for safety
systems that breakdown of covert was the
best i've ever heard thank you i have
never heard it anywhere else thank you
and will i hear it anywhere else who the
[ __ ] knows
and that's the problem
because by the way you just did yeah in
a few minutes
in in the most succinct way i've ever
heard and i read and listen to stuff all
the time you literally broke down not
only the problem but what incubates the
problem and why the problem won't go
away yeah yeah yeah okay in fact there
these [ __ ] are getting even
more funding that's like because they're
[ __ ]
because their [ __ ] is important like
funding is gonna be right i mean because
we're uh it's off the [ __ ] shots you
know
i mean the things they're gonna be
making now yeah yeah no no and just you
know there's more research for i mean
everything involved in this right and so
inevitably there's a little skepticism
around gain of function you know it's
like you don't want to call it that you
know but this is everywhere you know
it's like i have a you know friend who
um is um i'm gonna disguise his identity
he's a leading figure
in a film in a field that is related to
physics okay and it's related enough
that he knows physics quite well and i
was talking about
um him talking about this problem with
him
and um
he was like um oh yeah you know why you
know in physics it's so bad
that there are entire workshops about
string theory
that aren't about string theory they
just have to actually pretend to be
about string theory because the string
theorists are in command of the funding
because physics is funded by physics so
the thing is when that starts to happen
in like
the us occupation of afghanistan right
right you're basically just like the
idiots are in charge and doing idiotic
things and there is no accountability
for them anywhere in any possible way
shape or form right so let's get back to
the acid so um i think [ __ ]
deserve a break after that yes um anyway
so you're digesting it because that i
mean that by the way
and not even to just be you know overly
complimentary but like it's amazing that
that that not only has that not been
talked about more
um broadly right but it hasn't been
put in a context that people can
understand well and and not only
understand
that that this is a huge problem but
that
it is it is by design and the design
continue itself perpetuates yes yeah
yeah thank you thank you well thank you
this is poverty this is everything right
yeah right this is poverty this is
homelessness i was in san francisco
there are guys with like devil horns on
all fours
you were in door street you weren't in
doorstep where was i was in there
there was this was the piss
faralito eating a quesadilla and in the
mission and i'm watching all this stuff
go on and i love that city but it has
problems it has issues and i'm going and
i'm looking at that for 20 years and i'm
looking at these
compassion centers homeless centers
navigation systems navigate their
navigation and no one's in them and no
one cares no it's insane it has nothing
to do with anything and it's run by the
homeless industrial complex that's right
you know like and like the chief
executive i'm not giving too much away
but like the chief like expert of the
san francisco homeless complex yeah
was actually my girlfriend 20 years ago
oh my god
oh my
you did it
yeah right so so you know and that
really informed me a lot about this kind
of mentality right yeah um
anyway like yeah it's it's it's sort of
everything um
i've had this uh sore in my mouth on the
right side of my mouth forever and i
keep biting my cheek and any because i
keep biting my cheek which makes it
like gets like inflamed and i keep
biting it again
sometimes you can get by doing things
the hard way without realizing it but
when you run a business doing things the
hard way means you're holding yourself
and your business back
ship station gives e-commerce sellers an
easier way to manage shipping so you can
take all the energy that goes into
managing orders choosing carriers and
printing labels and use it to grow your
business
no wonder why shipstation is already
trusted by 100 000 sellers
you know what shipstation is basically
they run your back office they handle
all your shipping needs they work with
multiple carriers so you can be focused
on the important parts of your business
originations right oh yeah quality
control keeping customers happy
and shipstation is working with amazon
etsy ebay and more and they let you
automate processes like fulfillment and
tracking so you can save time managing
orders while keeping customers really
happy
you also get deeply discounted shipping
rates normally reserved for fortune 500
companies
98 of companies that use shipstation for
a year keep using it for as long as
they're in business
hey shipstation isn't magic but it will
make your shipping stress disappear
sign up using promo code tim dillon how
many day free trial would you think
they'd give oh man for free i mean for
free in this economy you can't give much
away for free i don't know a couple days
you'd think what
i don't know like maybe half of a day i
would think it would be 20 minutes
where they would give you a trial for
free
to see if you liked it sure do you know
what they're doing
tell them tell them what they get i
don't even know if this is smart
they're giving you so much 60 days well
they're gonna go out of business
60 [ __ ] days
are you nuts
how do you care about the customer that
much
go that's two months
go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in tim dillon
ship station
make
ship
happen and by the way not only have we
used this but you know who used this and
used our promo code and uses it for
their businesses sam talent to ship his
book he uses it he loves it he loves it
it works for him
so he is using ship station
shipstation.com promo code tim dylan
everybody loves athletic greens
everybody what do you take in the
morning it's good for digestion energy
it's simple
i like the taste i send it to family and
friends i bring it with me when i travel
don't you
yeah see i gave it to my mom
here's what it is
it's gut health more energy optimized
immune system
i mean what else do you people want
it's it's a mild tropical taste
because you know when you when you have
these uh healthy things
they sometimes you go oh i'm prepared
for it to be really gross sure and then
you try it you're spitting it out on the
subway you go
i don't want this
but athletic greens taste mildly
tropical um
and it's lifestyle friendly whether
you're eating keto paleo vegan dairy
free gluten-free it has less than one
gram of sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals
or artificial anything while still
tasting good tell me a story about
athletic greens so this is tell me
something about it so literally i want
to hear
from you tim literally tell me something
this is what rich people do you know all
the time they they get vitamin
injections it's hundreds and hundreds of
dollars money blood replacement therapy
this stuff is less than children
it's a lot it's a lot it is a lot but
this is less than a cup of coffee a day
it's less than three dollars a day why
you don't have to go to the doctor get
the injections but you take it and from
what i understand and because i've used
it basically you just throw it in some
goddamn water
and you put it in your [ __ ] box you
have to swear but sure yeah but i'm
passionate about it yeah i get it and i
swear all the time
it's just part of your vocabulary i
guess well if i care and i passionate i
swear if i didn't care maybe i wouldn't
swear
but i care
because
athletic greens
is helping people regular people every
day become gods
and it helps with inflammation it's
i mean and it you get inflamed by
everything now
so here's what i'll tell you folks i'm
not kidding about this joe rogan does it
he takes it
to make it easy athletic koreans is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
tim dillon again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim dillon to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
do it mom and and you like taking you
take it every day so just take it
um you know thank you for helping me
make my fake smooth brain just because
you look like a hockey coach from the
70s and it's
it's it's such a comforting form do you
use do you use let me here's the
question yes do you ever use the accent
do you talk in the new york accent i
don't i i just whatever accent i have
which is kind of i guess
east coast
vaguely racist right uh that's just what
i do i was in new york and i was hearing
you know
people talk the way my grandfather
talked and you know and i can kind of do
that but i also feel like i'm kind of
ripping off the sopranos or something
yeah i mean it feels kind of fake i have
a long island accent which i think is
it's in a weird way it's subtler it's
subtler it's kind of it has a little
hint of boston yeah new england
um so let's get to this get back to that
how much do we have here as long as you
want okay yeah okay okay okay
anyway you know this is just a lead up
from my biography so i drop out of grad
school in 1994 um and i'm also
really have a social life again after
really not having a social life in high
school and college because i was like
totally the wrong [ __ ] age right but
i started grad school i mean it was a
crime to go on a date with you yeah it's
insane yeah that's true right that's
right i wasn't really thinking about
that but you know like it's one very
true it's wild right so so you know um
you know but as you see i'm a normal
human being of course no but um um you
know yeah i know you're laughing deep
down inside me like never mind but
the um in any case i drop it to grad
school i'm like here's here's my plan
i'm going to drop out of grad school i'm
going to go succeed in the new cd-rom
and multimedia bubble
um and i'm gonna make uh what year is
this 1994. okay i'm gonna make a pile of
money i'm by the way gonna move my very
sophisticated girlfriend who is you know
seven years older than me and has issues
uh who i met on the internet because we
were both little rock stars in this
little [ __ ] literary group and use
that on youtube [ __ ] yeah talk bizarre
if you're out there listening um [ __ ]
yeah you know i was on talk dot bizarre
and all dot peeves i have like juvenilia
all over these things right uh and and
and really quality people i used to like
on all dot peeves i used to flame
charlie stross the well-known science
fiction writer all the time he now hates
me um all these people hate me it's
really sad um it's crazy that the
people's idea view yeah is radically
different
really from i i from what i find all
right or let's get this acid let's get
it out you can get this flattering [ __ ]
later yeah you know acid right so uh in
any case um
i drop out to work at this funky little
like hollywood associated company called
chaos tools we actually ever see the vr
film lawnmower man yeah lawnmower
maintenance that's when they made good
things oh that was [ __ ] amazing tools
did the graphics for low and more mana i
love it so i'm working at cashflow
people that i'm working on
xaos chaos tools uh you know are also
known as chaos inc and um they did um
you know photoshop plug-ins and they
also like they needed like they
basically did this project that was like
way above their britches it was sort of
like in the end the thing that i did
that actually kind of worked later
um but that was that's my like future
career this was my present one it was
actually a [ __ ] show and a disaster and
like an insane experience so this in
1997
like this collapses like you know my
whole social group has collapsed in a
series of like insane infighting because
we're basically like you know i'm maybe
more
asocial than some of these other people
but they're all sort of doing this thing
where they're well outside high school
but they behave like high school kids
right uh you know and i thought i was
doing something different but i was
actually doing the same thing and
many such cases as our president has
said and um
the um
and you know this explodes my
relationship with this troubled woman
explodes and basically all i have is a
job offer from a company in berkeley a
lease on an apartment and a company and
you know in berkeley and
some family back on the east coast
right so you know what do you do in a
situation like that so basically
my feeling was that the right thing to
do was to take a [ __ ] ton of acid and go
see the new john woo film i think that's
correct i think that was absolutely the
right thing to do in a way that was kind
of the birth i mean and when i say like
like i'm you know i was reasonably
experienced dropping acid by myself as
one should be i mean when a full-grown
man don't don't try this when you're 13.
but like you know
uh you can sit and like in the closet
you know for eight hours on acid yes
you're a man right you know um and
there's i mean it's not the only thing
can make you man it's just one of them
right you know so um it's a native
american ritual it's a native american
ritual exactly exactly exactly well i
didn't have any peyote and i couldn't uh
sit in this bookshop but uh smokehouse
but um i could go see and see the new
john woo film which i knew nothing about
which was in fact if you're familiar
with the film um it's called um
it's with um nicholas cage and john
travolta yes it's called face off that's
right and you know it has this wonderful
signature move where he's like
i'm going to take his face
and and absolutely brilliant and um and
you know so to see this with no
expectations no spoilers no nothing on
just like you know oh and it was also my
birthday
and and i forget that part um it was
1997 so i was turning 24 and i was like
okay um
why not do this and um i was like wow
you know we were talking about this
earlier on the show or perhaps before
the show i'm not sure when you started
filming and
um you know
it really is an important part of a
certain kind of experience and you know
that experience should be as intense and
disturbing as possible yeah and and and
for sure you know knowing that that ex
you know and now i'm going to describe
you know okay we're getting into the
difficult i guess we covered some
difficult political stuff earlier
uh you know we'll get to harder stuff
later maybe but let's go um you know so
but the next thing i did um which really
i think it
honestly i only lasted that's that this
company are the same are the same people
in silicon valley silicon i love that
you say silicone that's so like i know
it's so great silicon it's so great keep
saying no no no never change a friend of
mine does that and it's like perfect
yeah
are they the same people
because
when i look at the ruling class i feel
like the people that are there if you
look at the campaign contributions from
google they're about 99 blue
right but we know the least about like
we know what motivates wall street guys
it's a lust for gargantuan sums of money
yes
what motivates these tech utopians are
they is gonna surprise you i'm gonna
surprise you it's a lust for gargantuan
sums of money wow um okay and so
there you go
so so not to be too shocking here or
anything yeah right you know but um and
not that i mean is marin county
expensive i had no idea not now you know
and and and so you know i never actually
have really succeeded entirely in
silicon valley i'm sort of like semi
non-filled it was my next so i lasted
like nine months at this company i sort
of never quite clicked with them
socially i think i was just a little too
weird definitely the only one who ended
up with like weird politics very
apolitical time though um but you know
they were they were great the 90s was
great they were they were very political
and then i then i worked at the then i
actually made some money in the dot com
bubble which became my like nest egg to
do this and same thing that i did later
but let's go back to the start of this
company um we're not going to talk about
uh so i arrive at this company and i
start there and i was like wow this is
an insane experience we're not going to
talk about acid anymore um this is just
mushrooms um we're also not going to
talk about the time i smuggled mushrooms
back from japan
uh after 9 11 in a jar of miso we're not
going to talk about that that's amazing
um and um so yeah we're not going that's
like i think the statute of limitations
is bad but you know they will come for
you exactly they'll probably use that as
their excuse that'll be vanity fair's
next exactly
the man who drove america crazy right
with his you know anyway so um um the
music wasn't very good for them
you know in any case so um i have a bag
of mushrooms and i find basically um you
know the coolest person like the hippest
hippie dude he's wearing like tie-dye
at there and i noticed that the uc
theater the repertory theater right
around the block from her office is
playing a film
that i wanted to see
and so
i suggested this guy um his name was
jimmy hi if you're right there jimmy um
he's like i want to go see why don't we
take some mushrooms which is perfect
kind of timing for mushrooms is shorter
yeah
why don't we go take some mushrooms and
um
go see the film that's showing at the uc
and he's like what's the film i'm like
it's called das boot he's like what's it
about i'm like um it's like i don't know
footwear or something yeah i don't know
if i actually said that but
have you seen dust boat yes um uh have
you seen it on acid
not yet uh it has to be the dr you've
seen the director's cut right the three
hour version i've seen the really long
one the real yeah that's the director's
cut that's the director's cut you know
imagine like you're there right you're
watching the movie in the theater like
big big big sound yeah big sound big
sound big screen big picture you're like
you know basically you know 500 feet
under the street of gibraltar and like
british destroyers are trying to like
crush you in an instant yeah by throwing
garbage cans of tnt right into the water
yeah for about 45 minutes living in that
and that acme explosion of a car right
right it's not i mean it's not really
claustrophobic well it is called
claustrophobic right you know but um um
yeah he was i think he was okay with me
afterwards
the relationship never really became
warm you know
when when did you leave tech when did i
leave text
when were you just like i'm gone so
basically twice you've been writing
under mention small bugs i was writing
so i see
yeah let me like finish my like stupid
ass biography so um because i've told it
in the hopefully a non-boring way so
it's great so the um in any case so i
worked at this company um called it
first had this cool name of unwired
planet
um which was that's a cool name right
love it unwired planet and we did
smartphones before the smartphone we
were doing smartphones in the 90s wow
smartphones in the [ __ ] 90s we had
this modified version of html called wml
some of you [ __ ] out here are sold
that you actually work with wml um we
shipped about a billion web browsers and
i was the browser guy i wrote the
rewrote the browser core so technically
about a billion units of my code were
shipped for which we were paid nothing
at all and about like 30 000 people used
the thing actually and it was a terrible
[ __ ] user experience one time i was
actually actually tried to use it to get
directions yeah and like you know um
like 1999 i'm like trying to drive
somewhere and i'm like wow this is your
own cut you're using your own car i'm
using my own cut i tried to avoid using
it because it was just too embarrassing
i mean the thing is we didn't control
the end-to-end experience right like
this is how crazy it was at the firm in
berkeley um you know okay i named chaos
tools this is geoworks and um basically
we did the japanese were the people that
had smartphones first and the japanese
you know these japanese hardware
companies we were working with had this
idea about
how
to build smartphone software which was
very simple which is that they would
design the experience and we would they
would send us screenshots and we would
write code that looked like the
screenshots you will notice that for
example windows is not developed this
way
[Music]
this was basically doing software in the
way a japanese hardware company thought
you should do software right you know
software is one of the things the
japanese are notoriously worst at and um
and so you know this is a sort of very
painful experience kind of like you
wanna you know this is the future you
wanna do it but you're basically working
and it's just like completely [ __ ]
way um and then i moved to unwired
planet which was in the same industry
which was trying to solve
the same problem but they were like more
sophisticated and so they were building
like relationships and so they hired for
example this guy who is the former like
secretary of the interior under carter
or some [ __ ] like that and they knew how
to schmooze and their basic principle
was like we're going to schmooze it up
with the carriers and basically get the
carriers to ask for this product and um
and tell them about the wonders of the
internet and um i don't want to descend
too deep into like business speak here
for sure um but um
you know
this company was run by one of these
types you find in silicon valley named
alain rossman and alain rossman i'd
heard like really bad things about
elaine rossman from the geoworks people
because a lot of him then worked with
him at this att attempt to do mobile
phones in like 1991
early 90s which got like blown apart for
this guy anyway he was sort of one of
these like steve jobs wannabes and so
you know i sort of imagine him like
flanking the halls like um jeff goldblum
in um steve zazoo you know
right he was basically talked about as
if he was jeff goldblum and steve's the
sioux i forget it's the name yeah yeah
the uh underwater yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there we go there was accident
underwater and the water um and and um
so anyway so you know i moved to his
company because they seem to actually be
getting [ __ ] done in like
you know europe and america and um you
know meet this guy never worked directly
for him or anywhere close but he looks
like a homeless chess player but anyway
he has lynn is very very nice in belgium
you know um anyway so we have this plan
of basically creating this alternate
world of like self the cell phone
internet and um i was lucky enough to be
one of those you know there's sort of
three kinds of people in silicon valley
people who don't make any money there's
people who um
make money off [ __ ] that doesn't end up
working and then there's people who make
real money off of [ __ ] that works so
it's very lucky to be someone who made a
little bit of money off of [ __ ] that
doesn't work right anyway sort of the
the world conquering attitude of
phone.com which we changed our name to
which is sort of the cto was like
phone.com so we went to the dorkiest
name ever unwired planet much better i
know i know but it was the day of the
portal and our cto was like browsing the
domain name registry he's like i can buy
phone.com for fifty thousand dollars you
should have just kept it and uh and and
does this and then we become phone.com
and then we go public as
iphone.com.com and there was a little
contest within the company yeah to
choose the stock symbol that we would go
public under yeah
and one of my friends don't tell me it's
a like a phone
like an actual phone no no no it's a
four-letter symbol right
right right not a logo it's a stock
symbol right so a friend of mine was
talking my like office mate was talking
to me later he's like well you know i
was going to send in the suggestion that
for phone.com it should be phcm which
could be pronounced [ __ ] him
right and then he was like no that would
be unprofessional so we go public and of
course
not only is our stock symbol [ __ ] them
but we later merged with software.com
whose stock symbol was swcm oh
everybody's [ __ ] stuck [ __ ] them
exactly exactly exactly you said it
right you know i thought you know you'd
never get it but you know the the um um
in any case basically needless to say if
you bought [ __ ] with the ipo
you know at its peak it became like a 10
10 billion dollar company right if you
bought and held you know it became
worthless right so so you bought and you
sold when you sh you made a lot of you
made a lot of money and if you were
employed as a pre-ipo employee you're
going to stock you guys are not sure
this is the day of the classic stock
option so i basically wound up with i
think you know you know in terms of the
problem was i sold the stock and then i
bought other technology companies
because i was convinced that the future
was happening the future was in fact
happening it wasn't happening quite yet
right right so you know if you bought
like webvan stock because you believe
that online grocery delivery was the
future which i did and it was yeah 20
years later you still got [ __ ] in the
ass right right so you know where they
explain other people got [ __ ] in
that's worse other people ended up with
actual like tax liabilities anyway the
bubble explodes i switch companies you
know then i'm like okay wow you know i
had this plan when i dropped out of
school like that i was gonna do like
independent computer research science
research um i just met my wife at that
point um
and you know the company i was working
for which was like a japanese-owned
company that used to be remember the
palm pilot yes like they bought the code
for that it was it was a [ __ ] show um
and um
it was on its way down and everything
was on its way down and it was early to
you know 2002
um and i just met my wife and she were
we didn't get married for eight years
but she was like go for it right so i
quit my job and i was like okay i'm
going to do the thing that i wanted to
do when i dropped out of grad school i'm
going to basically do
effectively an you know unsupervised phd
thesis in computer science and so that's
kind of what i spent from 2002
to 2013 i spent doing um
and
by
like 2011 or 2010
um i had two kids and was completely out
of money um and
i'd also it was depending on the
kindness of my wife and my mother
neither of whom was rich my wife just
had a day job as a tech writer um and
they basically were like hey you know
you gotta actually fund this and make
this a thing or right get a [ __ ] job
because basically like heroes for the
last 10 years as a parent with kids
basically
no
income to speak of no savings and what
am i doing i'm doing these insane
[ __ ] projects one of them is just
this weird ass
blog right you know right and the other
was unqualified reservations unqualified
reservations right um which someone has
you know extracted from blogspot and um
which would have banned it long ago and
and put it up on
unqualifiedreservations.org by the way
my current blog is the greatest
that's gray within a the american way
and um and and the um
and you're writing this as a hobby yeah
i'm writing it as a you know it was a
hobby it's not there's nobody's blogging
as a profession in [ __ ] 2010 right
right so you know by 23 not even in 2013
right right so by 2013 basically like
you know you notice the readership
growing yeah the readership has
definitely grown right right now there
was definitely a real readership i was
definitely like a nano celebrity in a
way i was already used to being a nano
celebrity on the internet i was in in a
celebrity when i was 19 on the internet
but it was a much smaller like internet
it was just and it was not it was used
in that and it was not for landing it
was just in this it was for shaming that
writer and it was it was just in this
weird-ass literary world you know um and
uh which is actually like a lot of that
early using this stuff became
foundational and became sort of part of
core internet culture right like through
like a lot of it went to like something
awful right right you know um in any
case um
you know so um i basically stopped
blogging in 2013 because i had to turn
this thing into a company
um it's called orbit um this is it still
exists it's out there please don't look
into it uh it's not cool at all um and
um i mean that it's also too complicated
to use um and remember our talk about
barriers earlier yes um you do if you
have an iq of over you know 110 if you
don't never mind it doesn't matter right
um you know let's get some jokes drugs
drug humor right in any case um so um so
i started this thing and then um you
know of course because i have this
interesting like checkered
reputation um the association of my
checkered reputation and having this
like cool
insane because basically what i was
doing for those 11 years was i was
saying
okay
here's how we normally build computing
systems
this way that we do it comes is very
accidental and came out of history and
if you have literally if you're wearing
an apple watch it works the way it does
because it's basically
a
structural copy
of an ibm mini computer from or not
digital for a mini computer from like
1975. and because that's the way
computers worked in 1975 certain
decisions have been taken that can't be
untaken it's the way like evolution
can't design like a human with six arms
right you know right you just can't have
a mutation that does that and so you're
sort of locked into this one kind of way
of doing things and so what i was trying
to answer was the question of if you
rethought this from scratch like imagine
you get like a usb drive with like the
operating system from an alien spaceship
right and it's got it doesn't have
anything that reminds you of like a you
know they didn't have a digital
equipment corporation that made a
machine called the vax in 1976 right so
you know how's it going to work it's
going to be sort of completely
structurally
different and so like my thing is so
different this was stupid actually but i
was like this is going to be so
different that zero means true and one
means false right that's actually just
mathematically more beautiful um you
know for stupid way reasons it causes
all kinds of stupid bugs but any case
this is still this is still a thing this
is still a thing in you know uh 2022.
you can look it up because it's too
complicated it's too complicated and you
want to understand it and it's not cool
okay so in any case in any case
basically so i basically quit um
you know i um ejected myself i have
actually no association with the project
at all um now i do have some urban real
estate but i have no stock in the
company i have no power and i'm not
involved i don't i'm not i can't even
tell you how to use this thing right
actually it's probably too complicated
for me founders farewell there you go
um um um um ray right
was it amicable were you like on that oh
yeah i pushed myself out i was i was i
was always completely in control of the
company so um the um um the it was more
than amicable and i'm good friends with
the founder but again not very cool you
know what's cool is that picture there
that's a still from godard's contempt
yeah i was just about to say that's the
did you recreate no no no that's not me
that's that's bernardo you know yeah
that's so famous
i italian actor yeah it's actually an
italian uh that's actually the um that
is the via um god when we see you and
enjoyed anonymity for a long time well
here's actually no actually i doxed
myself fairly early in the blog here's a
funny story about the way i doxed myself
um what are you laughing at like a
lunatic just the
it's just a look because you said you
like you like the anonymity he goes no i
doxed myself very early yeah it's just a
funny quick yeah yeah yeah that's that's
a villa by the author of kapoot
with two t's look that up um he designed
this villa he was a fascist novelist um
he designed this great novelist he
designed this villa himself i just look
up uh caput with two t's villains um and
great having this guy i love real estate
yeah yeah this is amazing if i could
afford this if herbert takes over the
world oh my god no no no no
with a k k okay
with a k of course it's a k gotcha their
egg villa um look for the jesus
christian malaparte look up cruisio
malaparte curzio malapateo god you're
just dominated by like ad searches right
you know every internet is [ __ ] there
it is
you know probably yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the uh that that's the uh
stunningly that's the via mullah
stunningly beautiful and like this
modernist fashion
right there exactly exactly right as i
always say the art is the best part of
fascism and and the um um
especially in [ __ ] italy right you
can argue with that about germany it'll
leave this focus you know in any case um
um
sometimes i'm sad are you ever sad oh
yeah
how sad
depressed uh
full of uh right well
i also feel that way
but sometimes i want to make it stop
and you know what i do
do you use
what i'll tell you okay just tell me
yeah i go to better help
it's
it's you call people
there are plenty of ways to support a
healthy brain
like learning a new language or taking
power naps there's also better help
online therapy it's therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat only
therapy sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you could be matched with a
therapist guess how long
uh
very quickly i imagine but i mean how
long
i don't know like two months that seems
fast to me you think it's fast
two months you think would be fast my
experience with therapy it takes months
and months to get it stay with someone
you like it's taking you two months to
get a therapist it could take years
that's what you're saying 60 days is
that's what you're saying six months is
fast to me
well let me i'm going to knock your
socks off
they do it in 48 hours
i mean how do they do it oh my god
it's much more i've said that
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and care into keeping them
healthy with the minds yeah them healthy
okay
do it
go to
betterhelp.com that's that's
betterhelp.com
tim d t i m d
uh you get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
timd that's betterhelp.com
timd
where were we so yeah so um i docked
yourself earlier yeah i docked myself
early on so in the way in which i doxed
myself is somebody read my blog this is
a funny story actually with no point to
it but you know i basically somebody
contacted me and was like hey the way
you posted about computer science is
like sufficient i you know to identify
you emails me um and i'm like ah [ __ ]
you know anyone can tell and then this
is like 2009 or whatever and you know
in at the start of covid
i moved to a small town in um nevada you
know the nevada excuse me if you say
nevada in nevada you're gonna have
problems right um and it's like persians
and italians right you know and um i
just call the whole state vegas yeah
exactly so so so i moved to you know
kind of a northern suburb of vegas which
has a french i prefer to think of it by
the french name you know the actor who
was in the professional yeah john um um
your idea pardon no no no john john
jean you know
oh yeah so exactly if you if you know
yeah yeah if you're a you know it's
something
it's like saying you're going to target
right you're going to the target in
climbing right you know and um anyway um
so i moved to reno
or remo and um and i've become friends
with this um guy
el
who also from you know same general
vague community rationalists or whatever
in
and it turns out and i become very good
friends with them and then he's like you
know curtis did you know
that like in 2009
i was the one who sent that email and he
was like you know it was actually pretty
hard yeah to figure out who you were i'm
sure someone would have done it right
and so actually like operating out of
the closet has had a couple of different
effects it's had the effect of making
sure
that my like technical work like my
other
career
um
in like complicated computer science
[ __ ] um will always sort of be like
basically in computer science in systems
at least you're trying to establish like
a standard and so having
this um sort of baggage around
your neck for example there's a linux
file system called ricer fs which is
very innovative interesting file system
and was really one of the leaders to
become the future of linux you've heard
of linux this is nerd thing you know and
um
the file system is like a nerd part of
it like the liver the liver of the
operating system is the file system and
you can kind of swap them out which i
wish you could do with livers frankly
yes and um you can kind of swap them out
and rise rfs was the leading one and
then hans riser that like autistic
weirdo who developed and designed this
very innovative file system murdered his
wife right um and um the uh you know
let's get hans riser up here okay uh and
so you know i didn't murder my wife she
died of completely natural causes right
in the hospital yeah you know sorry
thank you thank you thank you um
and you can go to my website and you
know read my poetry better uh you know
and um the um
in any case um you know that that
crippled you know his adoption is a
standard right you know on the other
hand it's basically like having this um
yeah exactly looks just like me hair's a
bit shorter you know um and same we did
it right same expression in his eyes
right yeah exactly you know and um um
the
uh
technology that's right even though it's
actually genuinely brilliant technology
and hasn't committed any murders at all
hasn't committed any murders at all but
in any case basically but it's also like
not a sort of social network that like
people are on right and so you know in a
way however
so that's sort of a negative effect but
there's also kind of a positive effect
in that remember how we were talking
about burning man yes like the playa is
not the caribbean you know imagine if
they held burning man in like you know
fort lauderdale right you know like it
would turn into like you know
freak nick right
right right and it would not be an
environment in which anyone you meet is
an old friend you've never met yet right
so
and and so you know operating out of the
shadows has kind of created operating
out of the shadows creates this barrier
to entry where you're like okay but
there's something funky and weird about
it's
the founder he didn't kill his wife
maybe he was cancelled in some way right
do i dare to use this and the thing is
if you're a person who's answered that
question is yes bear in mind this is
like not something cool that you should
look into right okay and it's too
complicated for you to use it frankly
doesn't work very well you know i'm just
you know i'm not sure from what i hear
about the engineering since i left you
know
it's really it's just like you shouldn't
go there but the thing is basically like
like like um
you know having those barriers to entry
is a crucial part of like quality
control now the problem is of course
it's sort of also like an immigrant to
growth like clubhouse is another good
example of that do you remember club i
was big on it yeah i was in the
clubhouse too right and then i was at
the club and then and then separate
quality it had an eternal september it
had a real problem
and uh it was very fun very well
technically because it was it was a
small group of people
that and it was very interesting because
they would bring on like people every
now and then like i was a comedian so
like i would just sit in these rooms and
listen to tech guys talk mark andreessen
is on there like all the [ __ ] time
there would be a time to go this guy now
we need someone to be funny yeah and
then i'd be funny right and you and you
should have mark and you know go away
and then it all works do you want to see
like you should go and see if marc
andreessen will do your show because you
know yeah but then they there was like
they started doing like struggle
sessions right in the in the rooms and
then there was one room called
saudis and jews that got wild
that room got wild
every now and then have saudi have
treated you yeah yeah yeah yeah it gets
us back to the persians in the italians
it's degenerated so rapidly right right
right and it just became this like toxic
[ __ ] jungle right and this is what's
happening in america yeah kind of in a
lot of ways in your estimation we have
because it's not a democracy it is more
of an oligarchy yeah and that that's
been proven but columbia review or
prince interview one of them i think
columbia did a study where they went by
any
rational standard measure here this is
not a democracy no it's not like barely
you know who are the people even matter
right you know but yeah it's it's like
it's a [ __ ] show and it's basically like
you know these are sort of to the
corruption by like power that we talked
about in chronology and the sort of like
corruption by like low quality which
isn't really happening imagine if just
like there was like virology inflation
yeah so like anyone could call themself
a virologist right right you know or
like you could basically like harvard
like lowers the standards so you're
basically like you know harvard is
selling you know harvard virology phds
for 499. right right you know what
happens to the virology community then
and what do they start to believe right
well we just in my whole life all we've
ever seen is political scandals and
disasters with absolutely no
accountability yeah and so
and it's like culminating
right
and here is here is sort of the like the
thing is normally when you say
let's take power you're like okay you
have um you know let's get back to like
political basically we get back to
political theory here we were having an
interesting conversation
yes it was too fun
and um you know
i want to get people back to like things
that are hard to understand to drive the
stupid people away yes i want actually
your viewership to go down let's get
keep because let's get keep because
barriers to entry are really important
um in any case um
so to get keep a little
let's go
you basically
what you you know the sort of the first
conclusion to like jump to when you're
in um
sort of a problematic situation is
you're like okay
i'm in a problematic situation instead
of like trying to solve this it's like
debugging is sort of the art for this
you know if you're if you're a coder and
you you fix bugs you have the mentality
that the bug will never defeat you if
you're beaten once by a bug it like
changes you like honestly as a man or a
woman or a person um and um
and and so you never let that happen
right and so you have to have like
you know in order to basically step back
to a place where you know that you are
right about everything you have to say
let me start by assuming that i know
nothing and so i'm living in the year
2022
and like stuff is a little weird
right like the narrative is weird and
maybe it's weird like in the same way
that like the narrative was weird and
like the soviet union and you're just
like can i really you know the soviet
union actually it's funny there was i
you know i'd love an english translation
of this if like you're a rich person out
there there was something called the
great soviet encyclopedia that was
basically produced in like the 1960s it
was like soviet like wikipedia except it
was done by the you know right supreme
soviet right and so basically it was
like the soviet line on everything the
soviet line in literature the soviet
line on biology the soviet line on
history and so it would have an entry
first say the english civil war
which would be a soviet interpretation
of the english civil war it would have a
section on the revolutionary war the
american revolution that was a soviet
interpretation of the american
revolution and if you think there's only
one way to interpret the american
revolution well
like when was that ever true right you
know and and there's just like the view
that like you smashed america yeah yeah
yeah yeah can you do it very quickly and
i can do it very quickly um in like 15
seconds the american revolution is the
vietnam war in the 18th century it's
essentially a civil war between two
british political factions by proxy and
that's why the sort of violent events in
it don't really seem to make sense in
the same way that you look at the
vietnam war and you're like how is this
not like world war ii right you know and
that's the that's the that's the
american revolution um and a great way
to to um read about it is you just go to
google and you type in true history of
the american revolution
works fine um and um you'll actually get
a book that was written in 1903 just go
there um
so that's actually kind of cool see the
internet sometimes fulfills its promise
it has its perks like you know you know
when brynn and paige were like we're
gonna digitize all the books like right
before 1923 all the books that are free
they're like
they weren't thinking like what's the
average like political opinion before
1923 where is it in the overton window
it's not even in the overton [ __ ]
building right right
right even relating it to the overton
window it was hard right um you know and
so in any case
when you see this like problematic
situation
what you want to do is to go back to
like where you know nothing and one way
to do that is to go way back in time
and look at basically the first person
who ever wrote coherently about
political science assuming that nobody
knew anything is aristotle
and so
if you go back to aristotle's system of
political science first of all in the
same spirit as james burnham's the
machiavellians you don't actually need
to read the politics you should just
read the machiavellians
but um you know it certainly doesn't
hurt and aristotle points out that there
are basically three
forms of government
monarchy oligarchy and democracy
government of the one government of the
few government of the many when you're
identifying an oligarchy or aristocracy
your question is always who matters who
is in the loop right there's actually
this great armando yanuchi film called
in the loop like there's this whole like
little mini genre of like how the
government actually works which is like
the british show yes minister uh in the
thick of it all of yanuchi's films are
actually kind of like realistic they're
like more realistic than right they're
not completely real but they're like
more realistic than like cnn right um
and so
if you want to look at how things work
well the chronicles of narnia is more
realistic than c that may very well be
that has you know the the same initials
as well right you know and
the um
in any case um
so there's three kinds of government
there's monarchy oligarchy
and democracy the government of the one
the government of the few the government
of the many and when you look at the way
things work now it's essentially
an oligarchy of prestigious institutions
one way to ask the question of like
who's in power like how does power
actually work not like what's written
you know
in this piece of paper
but like
who actually matters is to say
imagine
and you can you have to be able to say
this for any regime any kind of
government so imagine that you're like a
nazi from outer space remember that film
iron sky you're a nazi from outer space
and your goal is to like turn the world
nazi your goal is to get as much nazi
power as possible so the question is and
you can you can take over a certain
number of people's brains you can like
attach a little like nazi unit to their
brain that turns them into like secret
nazis right so without revealing
themselves they try to kind of guide
everything in nazi directions right they
might be like you know
writing a story about epstein they might
kind of emphasize his semitic background
right you know and so they kind of try
and and sort of tilt reality and so and
i'm skipping you know ahead because the
question is who would they take over who
the answer would be i'm not sure which
institution they would want more whether
it's harvard or the new york times right
i don't know it kind of doesn't matter
or it's hard to tell because they agree
with each other completely like harvard
the state department in the new york
times like you know they're like peas in
a pod they never fight with each other
this is just like that cathedral where
you have all these
you know supposedly independent
institutions that all agree with each
other they come to the same conclusion
conclusions and those why do they come
to the same conclusion why do they let
me let me finish for a sec why did they
come to the same conclusions they come
to the same conclusions because those
conclusions act as political formulas
okay for exactly this system they cause
people to think basically
you know experts should be in charge and
we should give them a lot of money right
and so basically like nobody's in charge
of this right and the thing is when you
talk to people the more important they
get the more they will be like people
are locally in charge you have these
little emperors like the peter dazzacks
of the world right but overall nobody's
in charge of this thing and that's what
makes it an oligarchy and one thing that
you've said that's very interesting is
an oligarchy tends to produce a very
uneven disjointed
uh strategy for governance yes because
nobody's in charge right you know and so
because nobody's in charge in just you
know like there's no accountability like
there's no organization that can be like
you know that's sort of superior to
peter dazak that can say besides taking
like a vote of congress that says this
guy will not get any more funding
wherever if he doesn't get funding all
of his people will still keep getting
funded so there's no way to like cut off
that to amputate that right poisonous
arm right and so you know you have the
same critiques of society or or you
share some critiques with people
on the left like a chris hedges or sure
right absolutely absolutely it's very
easy to see like pieces of this system
and a lot of people see it very clearly
and it's your
liking like foreign policy like with
chris hedges i think there's like a very
similar take of this is like a
self-licking but his his take would be
strengthened public institutions more
unionizing more yeah which is like
giving more money to peter dazak right
you know and so my take basically i
don't know as a foreign policy take is
just shut it all down right close all
the bases all the embassies you know
what right if you want to deal with the
government of france send an email if
it's really complicated maybe you can
zoom so it's unwinding the empire it's
unwinding the empire it's it's an
american like gorbachev and and so the
argument or the question is what happens
in that power vacuum is to russia and
china sure but let's let's you know
let's well that's a pretty deep hole
okay hello to that hole sorry um and uh
it's a deep fun hole but let's pull back
to the basic like the basic political
theory yeah so what you're looking at
here is basically when you look at
democracy as a form of government
basically where power is actually
broadly spread across
the population and power in the sense
that the population is constantly sort
of making actual choices like any actual
power figure who's not symbolic
like you know let's execute socrates
would be an example of like a democratic
right
right you know and so literally they
executed the greatest philosopher in
history based on an internet poll okay
that's democracy right so you know more
generally the equation of democracy and
politics is interesting this is
something you can find people uttering
the same rhetoric
in the um
early 20th century where they basically
condemn
you'll notice that in the english
political language as it stands the word
politics has a negative connotation if
you're politicizing anything you're
going to politicize you as foreign
policy it's very bad but democracy has a
positive connection right right so what
gives right you know and it's like then
you're like basically you look around
the world and you notice you know weird
anomalous things like for example you
ever heard of north korea like do you
know the official name
what's the official name of north korea
i don't know the dprk it stands for the
democratic people's republic of korea so
that's one place
and three synonyms for democracy yes so
basically what democratic means today is
just legitimate in some abstract sense
right and so you know basically that's
how like the european commission which
is basically about as accountable to
like the like voters of europe as like
kim jong-un is to like might right
right you know um um is basically
represents democratic democracy and like
civil society that's another euphemism
for oligarchy that you'll hear um you
know
um um respected institutions how are
they respected you know it's like if you
go to wikipedia wikipedia has the policy
of reliable sources which are
prestigious institutions yeah and like
ostensibly that's sort of an objective
like thing in a way but if you go to
like the page for that and you know with
the question like what is a reliable
source uh basically what you'll find is
that a reliable source is a source yeah
that is reliable
um are these consolidations
are these consolidations of of power and
influence among elites inevitable they
are inevitable in an oligarchy and so
basically they're sort of an inevitable
part of oligarchical governance what
happened so the way the way they evolved
which is sort of useful to know is that
basically if you look at the us this is
like short simple u.s political history
it's like quickly as i can give it so
basically in the 1890s the us is in
what's called the gilded age um
and
power in that age is sort of
relatively decentralized and it's kind
of in the hands of
sort of corrupt politicians who are
easily bribed by like large companies
and it's the gilded age it's the robber
barons sort of all these stereotypes are
basically kind of true
um and government is basically
you know
the effect is like china like you'll
notice there's a lot of [ __ ] that was
built then they seem to have been able
to do things very very quickly uh they
also have something building 12 months
empire [ __ ] state building is like
you know being built faster than like my
friends like vacation house like there's
like there's some right there's like
some kind of capacity in that in that
society that has vanished it's also like
very corrupt which no one thinks is a
good thing and like there's just it's
like [ __ ] in a lot of ways right and
the thing is that um
the
power is not in the hands of
the sort of most socially dominant
classes at the time power is not in the
hands of the smartest people the idea of
a professor telling what the government
the government what to do would be like
having like a you know programmer tell
the government what to do would be like
what like why it would be insane it
would be insane right and and the thing
is but basically there's a kind of um a
sort of like a thermal inversion of
power whenever like the best and the
smartest people are not the people
running the show and so the old
intellectual classes sort of where this
movement starts in america at least in
britain it's the fabians in america it's
the mugwumps the literal
liberal republicans people like charles
francis adams jr who's like one of my
favorite writers ever his brother henry
adams who wrote the education of henry
adams they're kind of doings of this
very aristocratic imagine if like you
know um um
you know david foster wallace was also a
kennedy right you know like that's like
the level of status that's right
[ __ ] have they were
total blue bloods yeah right you know
and very sophisticated and also the best
intellectuals of their time right right
adams is the editor of the north
american review which is like the new
yorker of its time or rather the vanity
fair of its time and i'm sorry
and um
the um
and and um and so basically you have the
intellectual elites who are realizing
the power of like science and thought
who are like the head of this revolution
and then they look at the most important
function in the world government and
it's being run by these like corrupt
like boss tweed [ __ ] and like
[ __ ] irishmen i mean italians you
know and yeah and and like people have
just like know class and civilization
right you know and who are stealing who
are in fact corrupt and who have no
vision whatsoever and are just like
letting [ __ ] happen and why did the
empire state be gilding you know um
you know get built in 12 months because
like you know some whop made a million
dollars on the permits right you know
and you're just like this is
unacceptable like this is not a way we
can live right and so basically
that turns into this philosophy of like
contempt for politics and politicians
and the idea that this should be this
sort of cosmetic process and then real
policy should be made by experts and so
experts who are people who have
universities can't we can't build any
affordable housing so basically here's
here's like the biggest mistake in a way
that was made with this you know when
you go sort of very very far back
they're like okay democracy doesn't work
democracy doesn't work because basically
the people will just have their votes
stolen by these like clowns the people
do not vote for philosopher kings they
do not like philosopher kings they vote
for like thieves and clowns it's like
imagine you know think about elections
and what about george w bush think about
elections in some you know america at
the time you got to remember america at
the time is a third world country it's a
rising third world country right and so
you're like basically you know let's
think about a random third world country
let's say paraguay do you know anything
about paraguay not at a time you think
the citizens of paraguay are entitled to
you know are actually capable of like
devising the right policies for the
future of paraguay not at this time not
not at this time that is an excellent
answer not at this time you know and and
and and you know that leaves the
possibility okay that leaves open the
possibility that the citizens of
paraguay could be educated you know
their brains could be extended with
additional lobes you know they could
become like citizen philosophers like
the citizens of athens who executed
socrates you know right i'm not saying
this couldn't work and you know one of
the things you see is that as systems
become smaller and more like democracy
at burning man it's not a democracy but
you could imagine it being democracy it
would still probably be [ __ ] right but
like you know currently it's some kind
of oligarchy or you know it's a complete
autocratic despotism yeah right you know
you could imagine it um as a democracy
and maybe that would not be [ __ ] right
but if you try to imagine
say
um let's make say since we mentioned it
detroit is going to be democracy yes and
then the citizens of detroit will elect
a king of detroit who is actually has
absolute emperor of detroit who has
absolute power over detroit right you
know are they gonna like or that no even
better let's say direct democracy they
will decide the laws of detroit
themselves and they will execute people
by internet polls that like work if
you're only geo-located to detroit you
know right
yeah
you know i like you're just imagining an
insane
did anyone ever believe in democracy um
so democracy basically you know if it's
funny if you go to the wikipedia page on
athenian democracy right there's an
interesting line from a modern scholar
yeah which is like you know it's
interesting that so many cultures have
tried to copy this system of government
and all we have
all the writing all the writing from its
own period was just like this was the
worst [ __ ] show ever devised right you
know and so even it's kind of this best
case scenario basically
like what you're seeing is like it had a
really checkered reputation and it was
considered basically you know between
you know
until essentially the like 18th or maybe
even early 19th century
it's generally considered a slur it's
like saying fascism or communism right
it's basically democracy is like mob
rule and everyone knows that's bad and
so it was you know then right
in school when we were being told about
democracy they would they would always
say we are a republic right because we
don't want mob right and yes and so and
that was what that reflects is basically
the original foundation of the
constitution which is basically the
constitution is a right-wing coup and
it's a right-wing coup because the
articles of confederation which are much
more democratic and much more rob ruley
mob ruling and much more jack ben as
they would have said in those days
because remember the [ __ ] french
revolution was [ __ ] going down that's
right right you know and it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show and like thomas jefferson is
over there basically being like the jane
fonda of the french revolution right you
know and he's he's like oh yeah you know
we got to kill some aristocrats you know
the blood of the you know the the tree
of liberty right you know um you know
thomas payne is even worse thomas paine
basically goes over there and he's like
those americans who like went to china
and like hanging out with mao right you
know and um um you know um
he gets so into french politics he gets
himself a [ __ ] trouble right you know
and um so
the americans of who created the
constitution notice that you don't know
anything about the articles of
confederation period except that it
happened
interesting and complete historical
blackout it's a complete you know any
names of the people involved events 13
years of american history right you know
like counting the like i mean the cons
it has continuity with the whole
revolution there's a congress during
that whole period right it's an utter
[ __ ] show and um states are like almost
going to war with each other
like rhode island basically has to
almost be convinced to join the
constitution by a [ __ ] blockade right
right you know um crazy ass [ __ ] right
you know and i mean crazy ass [ __ ] goes
like american history before the
revolution is like that's a period of
like over 150 years you've never heard
of like lives
rebellion and [ __ ] like insane the
regulator war never heard of it right
you know insane historical blackout [ __ ]
just because
anyway i'm a public school kid literally
history started with lizzo yeah history
started with lizzo yeah so basically the
constitution you know um which they did
mention a couple of times you know as
like it was you know written but printed
by god you know as they say in utah and
um the constitution is a right-wing coup
right that basically intends to install
this like dual very silicon valley
structure it's like you know um eric
schmidt
page
no no what it's actually installing is
basically a monarchy right with george
washington as the like figurative
monarch and alexander hamilton is like
the startup ceo dude who actually does
everything right right right and
alexander hamilton by the way was a
black man
let's just go with let's don't don't
don't question don't no
stay off the [ __ ] internet don't go
stay on the [ __ ] internet alexander
hamilton was a black man okay he may not
have been a black man but how much do
you like your job alexander hamilton was
a black man is that what is that really
the going thing now
okay no it will be
alexander hamilton alexander hamilton
yeah yeah yeah an african-american
gentleman yes was the first king of
america okay and so you know basically
he is running the us government like a
startup right completely in charge of it
he's like [ __ ] elon musk and
nominally he's the secretary of the
treasury jefferson is the secretary of
state he's just like this hamilton
[ __ ] is running everything right
what the [ __ ] right you know of course
he is because he's basically thomas
jefferson is a wonderful eccentric guy
just kind of a blow heart and like
hamilton actually knows how to get into
things yeah he's getting [ __ ] done right
and um so if you look basically at
american history it's again pulling the
camera away the [ __ ] back it's this
constitution is this really cool design
because it basically has structures that
are designed to be stand-ins for sort of
all three forms originally it was
designed for the set for the house to be
very democratic which is why like the
mob power now of course the house has a
98 percent incumbency you know race
right and security rules that were
basically appear to have been copied
from the most serene republic of venice
right and so it's this amazing bulwark
against democracy
um and it creates like the nancy
pelosi's of the world that you know make
make um
you know uh the supreme soviet look like
the baltimore orioles but you know the
the um
in any case
um the original design is like you take
all three
forces in government the force of
democracy
the force of um absolute aristocracy
right senate the senate was supposed to
be right aristocratic and it was for a
while before like the 15th whatever and
whatever the gas amendment the
directional direct election of senators
and um
the um
and then the presidency was the focus of
monarchy right and this the supreme
court was originally supposed to just be
like digital organ but again that's
another structure of oligarchy and
that's a very very low frequency
oligarchy right it has very slow
turnover
right and then the like power dynamic
between all of these institutions is
left entirely unspecified this is how
basically in a way it's sort of
hamiltonian government is like killed
with marbury versus madison which you
probably read about in public school
where the supreme court is like no
actually i read the constitution and it
doesn't say this but they meant we're in
charge right you know and so
what's neat about this system and what
has made it like survive a lot of crises
that really probably should have killed
it
is that basically about every 75 or 80
years
you have a regime change in the united
states you have a replacement of like
the whole actual structural forces of
government
under the same name which is a very
common thing in history um
and at least
go into this more and it leads to like a
different structure of forces so basic
and and it centers around a president
who is actually a monarch not in that
they call themselves king as you know
the roman emperor has never called this
valerian didn't call it ftr is an
example fdr is an example and who else
lincoln lincoln there you go so
basically what you have in all three
cases is you have basically this startup
regime
and this startup regime in lincoln's
case one of the interesting things about
things about lincoln from a silicon
valley i'm just going to start saying
silicon valley you know sounds better it
sounds better right you know and it has
all these like salacious overtones yes
you know and and um you know one of
these silicon valley things is that you
look at the lincoln administration and
you notice that the lincoln
administration is run by this like
weirdo self-educated wild genius
political talent abraham lincoln really
the first great american politician um
and some might say jackson some might
say van buren like lincoln is like a
combination of jackson and van buren
right you know and he's like a
machiavellian genius and he's also like
a genius orator and he really convinces
people to this day like think that
lincoln had like some kind of like
philosophy lincoln's philosophy was
whatever is good for abraham lincoln and
um you know and he was a master
politician
and basically um fdr's philosophy is
also whatever is good for fdr i think
i want to think washington and hamilton
are like pure um but the thing is even
with this level of like you know i don't
really approve of lincoln and fdr i
don't approve of a lot of things that
went on in their regimes
um however
one notices a couple of things about
them one is that basically if you look
for example at the lincoln
administration you'll see that a lot of
it the government the linking controls
mainly focusing on the war effort is
controlled by these young 20-something
guys
uh nicole and hay hey uh later becomes
the secretary of state and like the
mckinley administration and you're just
like ah-ha i see an organization run
absolutely from the top down by a pair
of guys in their 20s right where have i
[ __ ] seen this before right you know
facebook yeah
where have i [ __ ] seen this before
yeah and they win right you know
and um they win because they're awesome
and then you basically see that these
regimes are created as this minor these
monarchical structures then kind of
central power kind of decays and they
become oligarchies and it's like once
there were like wires going up to the
wheelhouse and the wires are cut why
does central power decay central bower
decays because
everything you know it's like that's
asking why do people die people all die
for a different reason they die in
different ways let's get forward to the
fdr regime so the fdr regime is this
quintessence of this like university
driven revolution because they were
there for universities for 100 years ago
for the [ __ ] for the [ __ ] upper
class they're from you know for like a
500 families like the people that
actually matter in this country like and
um
the you know this is a revolution of the
university class fdr himself personally
like lincoln i guess is not really a
manager fdr is actually in some ways a
lot like trump he's a very vain person
he's quite intelligent he's like not
really into books he's like totally
dominates a rome when he comes into it
he's like the most charming person in
the world very shallow but there's a
huge difference between fdr and trump
was which is that fdr is from a super
like one of the most aristocratic
american families roosevelt he's the
roosevelt's he has huge confidence and
he knows how to delegate because every
time trump tries to delegate he's like
can i trust this person right what if
he's trying to become bigger than me you
know what if steve bannon is trying to
exceed me and like right he's like the
worst [ __ ] you know anyway i don't
say i want to say i hate being saying
bad things about people even if they're
donald trump right um you know i think
donald trump would make an excellent
chairman of the board and that is the
right job for him he should be promoted
it's a promotion it's a more important
job being chairman of the board than
being ceo and so donald if you're
listening you know stay off of orbit but
um also oh he's going on earth
he's on his way to urban stay off of our
bit and start thinking of yourself as
like the like ceo emeritus and you've
made it so anyway yeah so getting back
to fdr and like this is sort of the
birth of what we call the deep state
right originally a turkish word i think
first popular i was by my friend steve
saylor and um peter dale scott had deep
politics yeah yeah yeah yeah it's close
it's the same basic thing yeah right you
know um you know scott was very familiar
with like the sort of you know
foreign like the eight industrial
complex
you know which my father worked for you
know and the whole foreign policy
insanity
yeah the whole apparatus you know that's
just one arm of this deep state that was
created by trusting the experts right
you know nobody even knows what it's
[ __ ] for anymore right right nobody
even knows what it's [ __ ] for and um
people just like make up reasons like we
got to predict all the viruses right you
know that is the level of like top level
geostrategic thinking and u.s foreign
policy is at the level of let's collect
all the viruses right um you know but
going back to sort of the the you know
the birth of this system like
there's a couple of things that i say to
describe like the new deal
and the new deal era um one is i was
particularly struck by
a book in theodore white's making the
president in 1960 a very famous
political book in which he's talking to
one of the kennedy people or one of the
older people who's kind of involved in
like the new frontier and we when we
think about the new frontier we think
about the kennedy world and there's this
kind of edge of monarchy to like kennedy
world because this is a big family and
right you know roosevelt had kids as
well but they were just like incredibly
corrupt incompetent [ __ ] there was no
way to take them seriously as
politicians you know unlike say teddy
kennedy right maybe it was more serious
time as well but the thing is you see
all of these monarchical complex
complexes developing
right and so you see that when you have
someone like fdr who i encourage like
all of my fans but especially the libs
to think of when they think of as
monarchy when you see someone like fdr
basically
like you know and you see that okay he's
not technically a hereditary monarch but
like the sort of attributes of
hereditary monarchy that are like
hereditary succession start forming as
they have formed for thousands of years
throughout human history so like you
know you start to from this perspective
you start to lose your kind of temporal
exceptionalism you're like history isn't
ending at all and like government is
kind of the same thing it's always been
right right and and you know if
government is the same thing it's always
been it's easy to look at fdr's world
and see a couple of different things one
is remember i was talking there was a
guy like
t h white um t e white something will i
forget his name um author of making the
president making the president 1960 is
um
um yes yeah um
he's talking to someone who remembers
the new deal era
and um
he's um
basically in the new frontier act and
when we think of like the new frontier
in camelot this is like the most
exciting time ever this is like my god
like being a frontiersman like yes you
know
like you know kennedy has robert frost
read it as inauguration biden has amanda
gorman right one of these things maybe
not quite like the other right you know
like and so you have this like you know
excellence right
at the at the top and the sense of like
heredity sort of forming
and you're just like what is this how
what is this like kennedy cult of the
kennedys have to do with like
the american revolution right you know
and um and so you're seeing all these
things develop those things are way more
intense in the roosevelt era this guy
who remembers the new deal is like oh
yeah you know everything seems kind of
dull and drab in the new frontier to
anyone who remembers the new deal that's
how like how much [ __ ] startup energy
then you had it's like working at google
in 2003. right basically you know here
is you know let's say you graduate from
harvard in like
1936
versus 2016. if you graduate from
harvard in 1936 with a degree in this
new field of economics a field that has
basically been completely reinvented in
the last 20 years um you're like oh you
know i'm a harvard man i'm really smart
and i know somebody who knows somebody
who knows tommy corcoran
or felix frankfurter or someone like
that and somebody calls somebody and i
get a phone call and they're like would
you like to come to dc yeah
yeah con you know concealing your
excitement you're like sure okay i'm not
doing anything else this time of year
and you come to and but what would i be
doing and um you know the voice on the
phone is like we don't know and it
doesn't matter come to dc right and you
come to dc and somebody puts you in an
office and is like okay
your job is to go here's five million
dollars your job is to go electrify
arkansas like you know that's the medial
experience that's a [ __ ] startup
experience and you're like 21 right and
you're like okay and you get it [ __ ]
done in like nine months yeah right and
and like that is what created the
enormous faith in like the powers of the
us government that people had at that
time it actually the new deal actually
got [ __ ] done and um
ever driven on route one yeah project of
course imagine that happening now
imagine you know right it is the laugh
right you know and so it's this
amazingly effective thing it's full of
the best people in society
um and it's like incredibly dynamic it
gives you incredible levels of like
personal responsibility at incredibly
young ages now imagine you graduate from
harvard in 2016 with a degree in
economics you're like okay i'm going to
apply for an unpaid internship on the
hill do they buy their interns i don't
know
right you know
in any case you really should have
family that can help you out because you
got to spend thirteen hundred dollars
right on a room the size of a shoe box
and then you're on somebody's staff
you're answering letters from pork pie
iowa yeah and then you know like did
they ever write that you know even when
you after 20 years you're not even
writing legislation certainly the
senators like the you know the
congressman never write any legislation
they barely look at it they pass these
bills they haven't even read the staff
doesn't even write the legislation they
get they collect they edit the
legislation they get lines from like
lobbyists and activists which are the
kind of two real sides of congress right
and you're just like this is like this
insane thing and like as a young person
there's just no like joy in it so as a
young person your mind naturally turns
after 75 or 80 years and by the way let
me finish explaining what happens at the
top so fdr is a not a brilliant manager
he's a brilliant collector of talents
he's like more like peter thiel than
elon musk right and so he basically
collects these entire talents at the
head of these or this organization um
and does all these like completely
unethical things about world war ii i
always recommend nicholson baker's book
human smoke um it's sort of one of the
few
it sort of gives you the right mood of
world war ii which is not a marvel movie
um and um that's you know as much as i
want it is not a marvel movie right you
know and and and so
fdr in 44
realizes that he's dying anyone who's in
the node knows he's dying remember the
[ __ ] people out there are so
brainwashed by the cathedral of that
time they don't even know he's paralyzed
interesting they don't even know that's
right they don't even know he's [ __ ]
paralyzed they don't know he's had like
a private subway station in new york for
like you know it's like this is a level
at which like if you look at the
distance at the level how easy it is to
like contain the truth from the
perspective of the media yeah at that
time it's just like this right you know
it's amazing right you know it's
orwellian like orwell worked for the bbc
right he knew this right you know and so
or um roosevelt in 44
he's dying he knows he's dying
everybody's in the no-nos he's dying the
public is informed that he's in the best
of health fit as a fiddle right and
anyone who looks at him can see he's
dying and so his previous um you know
vice president has been henry wallace
now one thing to understand about the
30s which was sometimes called the red
decade is that in the 30s everyone who
was cool was a communist yeah right okay
um just read a book by eugene lyons
called the red decade and you'll see
that clearly communist or a communist
sympathizer my grandparents were
actually communists this is a
non-debatable historical fact right so
uh you know but basically the communists
are at this time they're selling like
one or two percent of the population if
you look at the people who voted for the
same guy henry wallace in 48 when he ran
on the progressive party ticket note
that word progressive yeah that's also
what my grandparents called themselves
in fact they were card-carrying
communists right um you've heard that
word somewhere else progressive right um
and uh its meaning has never changed
it's just like most people who call
themselves progressives don't even know
the history of the word right they're
like those people in like new mexico who
still practice like the jewish rituals
you know but don't even know other jews
you know um and um but that's where you
know the like even cancellation that's a
that's a communist practice that comes
from an internal like like internal
you read a book called the romance of
american communism there are all these
like cancellation memoirs from like the
50s right from inside the party um and
so anyway
but fdr realizes that
he intends to found a regime he intends
to found
something that is his that will last for
many years
certainly into the 2020s
after him
and therefore
america must no longer be a monarchy
what must happen is that basically all
of these bright amazing people like the
best and the brightest right you know in
the 60s it's still kind of the best and
the brightest you can use that without
like joking like nobody nobody would
describe like susan rice is the best and
the brightest right you know and um
she's not dumb right um um you know
actually her son is like a famous based
stanford person yeah um susan rice is
not dumb uh this is public
and susan rice is not dumb um for sure
she's not dumb she's not dumb but she's
not [ __ ] um dean atchison correct
john bolton is also not deniation you
know i read [ __ ] john bolton's book
and he's like basically he's like i am
the second coming of dean atchison yeah
he's like you have the same muscles
and avoided wars yeah well you know
exactly i can say some things about the
united states sure but you know but i
mean john bolton loves uh yeah yeah
yeah yeah in any case basically like
these are pygmies right you know and and
so you know what you see is basically
fdr does this pharyonic thing
where as a successor and vice president
in 1944
he picks harry truman
and who the [ __ ] is harry truman
harry truman is a nobody
so what and like he's a nobody of like
very limited intelligence very limited
he's not
really prominent he's a member of like
the pendergast boss faction he's not
even a progressive democrat he's not
even a new dealer right and so basically
by by picking someone who's not even a
new dealer which is a master stroke it
was fdr's finest stroke because he's
basically saying who is going to succeed
me the answer is a nobody right and it's
immediately reminiscent of alexander the
great when he was dying i don't know if
this story is true story i've read it's
cool story he's dying and all of his
like henchmen he's like 30 or something
all of his henchmen are gathered around
him and they're like who shall inherit
the empire of alexander who shall be the
next you know who shall the kingdom go
to who should the empire go to and his
last two words are tokratos
which means to the strongest
ah
and so you know almost these these
people almost like figurative like like
pull out their [ __ ] surroundings and
like the funeral right right you know
and so
but fdr is doing something slightly
different by saying power should go
to nobody he ensures that
harry truman does not have the gravitas
or power to actually command the deep
state that's right and so he basically
lets the deep state command him and give
him little teleprompter scripts to read
he's not like demented and he doesn't
start reading the directions on the
teleprompter but he basically is like
inaugurates the era of the kind of
semi-figurehead president president and
power has a va you know since he didn't
and by the way
to eisenhower eisenhower's openly saying
yeah i don't really know what goes i
don't i don't really know what goes on
right and since then nixon does this
thing nixon does this thing where he's
like no i will really be the president
and try to regain commands of the
bureaucracy good luck this is the way
bolton and barr also think right bolton
and barr also have this thing of like
let's actually try to where are the
grown-ups in the room we will actually
make the us government work no you won't
you [ __ ] you know and like go like
shave your mustache and retire right you
know and and so um that basically sort
of brings us to the like political
structure of today that's how we got to
the oligarchy we're in today if you pull
back from that story of like where the
deep state is the new deal
it's the personal regime
of fdr without and the new deal fdr the
new deal comes into play
all of the people the architects of the
new deal become the heads of all these
institutions
all of these institutions are now
more powerful than harry truman great
foundation right it's a great foundation
you know like carnegie rockefeller ford
there's a whole philanthropic industrial
and all of these and they all have
exactly the same [ __ ] ideas and these
ideas are like dumber than a post and
smell like [ __ ] does this
does this structure work at all does it
work at all no it has to be completely
ripped out yeah and here is basically
the problem is that it has to be
completely ripped out and the only sort
of form of government that can rip it
out is the same form of government that
the u.s goes through every 75 or 80
years which is the monarchy which is
basically and so is the worry because a
lot of people that say that read your
work and say it's very interesting but
they go the people that really also
seem to like it are people that
love or seem to flirt with the idea of
theocracy so so yeah so you know it's
funny you should use the word theocracy
right tim you know because have you ever
seen signs on people's lawns that tell
you what to think
no no for sure like and and that's
another kind of theocracy and so yeah so
so so in a way it's like it's an
interesting point because in a sense
like
you conclude when looking at history
that sort of the libertarian kind of
freedom of speech world has never
exactly been a thing right and so your
question of how to sort of do something
like that is like basically what you
have to realize is that most human
beings will sort of always believe what
they're taught to think right and
therefore control of what they're taught
to think is sort of always in the hands
of someone and it should be in the hands
of someone responsible who has no need
to tell anything but the truth who has
an incentive to tell the truth and
that's not that's not the religious
right and it's not the no
no no it's it's no one it's like
basically and here's the thing you know
you get into like this like culture war
like [ __ ] like okay like and and i'm
just like i have less and less patience
i'm sorry i have less and less patience
for this [ __ ] yeah right you know and um
when we go back to like roman
history
you know
and
one of the things we see in again
pulling the camera away the [ __ ] back on
the history of the roman republic what
we see is that for like 400 years
there's something called the conflict of
the orders and at first it's patricians
versus plebeians
later i'm going to butcher the latin
it's optimales versus populares it's
basically you know of tomates are the
aristocracy the blue state popularizer
the red state you know uh the populace
right you know and so even now you can
just you can just sort of discern right
and left and so in the late roman
republic basically this political
conflict degenerates into actual civil
war because these people had like
well they had like balls they had like
normal testosterone levels they like
know how to like fight
each other and they were like normal
human beings they also didn't have
postmates they also did on postmates
right right
all the time also doordash uber right
you know life was a lot harder they were
harder yeah you know we can go into the
whole technology thing this is getting a
little long so maybe it may be in a
different episode yes um but um um i i
hope you're having fun no i'm i'm listen
this is fascinating
amazing stuff all right all right
really all right all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna run under the scene soon uh my
caffeine is gonna wear off but uh let me
so so let me talk and your brain is
probably full um which i mean it's it's
it is full but it's it's it's really
this is really interesting stuff
and again the the i think yeah let me
let me let me finish let me finish with
a little bit of roman political okay and
let's we'll get off of political science
and we can have a little chill yes area
you know when we talk about sports or
something you know um and um you know
because you're probably an islanders fan
are you an islanders fan
i don't care okay i mean i i've left
long island that's fine that's why i
have beverly hills i know i'm persian
now i'm different
arab the way the way
if you want to like get as i call it
like clear pill yeah the way to
basically get your head out of this
culture war [ __ ] is to take that
attitude toward the islanders and apply
it to the republicans and the democrats
that's right
it's incredibly refreshing and it will
leave a chunk of neurons in your head
that is the size of a [ __ ] baseball
free to think about other things that's
right okay so um um you know and um
and there are many like i'm not even
saying don't think about political
science i'm saying take a break yeah
from thinking about political science
yeah and um you'll have that baseball
free and then maybe that baseball can
come back with like aristotle and james
burnham and stuff but just let it rest
right let it chill out let it become
like like like soft like kobe beef yes
okay so you know um um the um
because it needs a [ __ ] break after
these last few years you know and and in
any case in rome you had um you know the
conflict of the orders
you know in like 1890 bc or whatever it
becomes
a civil war and it becomes a civil war
between these two tyrants
marius and sula who are kind of the
hitler and stalin
of the ancient roman world and they're
the hitler and the stalin of the ancient
roman world because they sort of they
are monarchs and they rule as monarchs
as effectively kings but even when they
become
de facto and they never claim the title
of king the caesars never did right and
rex which means king is never used you
know by you know the emperor's imperator
just means commander
in any case both of these cats um
you know
are um
they're leading a faction in the civil
war and when their faction wins and
dominates all of rome they basically
govern from one side so when you're
talking about like the religious right
you know or the woke left and you're
imaginating imagining a dictator who
really believes all of these things with
like the power of the religious right
and the woke left the religious right
you know as michael anton calls it the
red caesar comes to power
you know and he's basically like um
band's birth control and then i awoke
left you know comes to power
and basically he makes everyone get it
men take birth control makes men take
exactly right makes men take birth
control yes [ __ ] genius comedic line
uh you know and uh
makes men take birth control and you're
just like no right and so you know what
each of these individuals specifically
in do is when they come to power they do
this thing that's called proscription
that's like prescription like your
adorable prescription but with an o and
what proscription means is that
basically you take your prominent
enemies you kill them and you give them
money to your friends so imagine if like
donald trump is like now we're going to
execute steve bannon and like we're
going to give the money
you know we're going to execute sorry
george soros and we're gonna give the
money to like steve bannon and his
friends right right and then you know um
then barack obama you know after being
like chased through the swamps the
stories of these individuals are
incredible barack obama takes power and
he's like now we're going to take all of
peter thiel's money and give it to you
and we're going to give it to the
underprivileged right you know and also
to george soros right you know
um and also the under privilege but as
well like
right you know and um you know of course
by far i'm sure you know this by far
most billionaires and especially old
money is blue um and and the um but it's
[ __ ] not all of them not all of it
yeah but most of it right you know and
in the the size of like you know
progressive philanthropy as compared to
the size of conservative philanthropy is
like comparing a burger king to in and
out burger right um and but i also think
the definition of blue has changed
because if you look at the military
industrial complex some of those people
are they're identifying as blue but yeah
even though the blue is seeping yeah
it's no longer hillary clinton
she doesn't feel blue to me i mean i
know she's blue yeah it depends it's no
longer the age of general jackie ripper
that's true right right you know um and
so in any case basically like these
civil wars are like a very bloody time
right and so you know you have this
reaction to these civil wars like sula
wins in the end and he's like i am sula
i will restore the republic but he can't
really restore the republic because the
republic at a certain level you know
it's like paraguay right not at this
time
not at this time
you know the only question is sort of
who's basically going to rule and i have
two stories about that one is um
caesar and augustus the caesars
basically sort of find this kind of
different pattern
which works they're not red or blue
they're this is the most unoriginal
metaphor ever they're purple and they're
purple not in that they're centrists
that they want to diffuse power between
both of these groups oh no they're
monarchs right but they're purple
monarchs they're not there is no red
caesar red caesar is marius blue caesar
is zula right but caesar is purple
caesar which is also of course the color
of empire right um as well as you know
traditionally associated with
homosexuality many of these emperors
were gay right and in fact what's called
this other theory that's what's called
the five good emperors yeah it was
actually this like sort of little in gay
ring that was going on um and we need a
gay we need a gay seizure to kill right
i'm like some say we need a reds in fact
yeah tim i'm not yeah anyway um um you
know some say we need a red caesar some
say we need a blue caesar yeah it's
possible that following the example yeah
of you know is antonina's what we really
need is a gay caesar but um the um but
also hitler was gay but um yeah i don't
want to go down that rabbit hole but
hillary's okay but um um in any case um
sort of
disappoints so many of his fans
well i know i know i i actually had this
argument on a podcast with like a real
white nationalist podcaster and you know
uh like some people were very mad about
this gay hillary thing uh you know i
think it's very clean libs could be mad
about it too sure i think it's very
clear yeah you know um and you know if a
major leader is not surrounded by like
woman that he's like banging right
there's a reason for that for sure what
is the most obvious reason for that what
about american recent american president
never mind uh you know in any case i
really don't want to go there but um you
know in any case um the uh
so caesar here's his anecdote about
caesar caesar is is comes from the
popularis yeah he starts as he starts as
a red state politician imagine him as
like desantis also a military man right
um and he's basically like fights in the
civil wars
i'm not saying desantis is as cool as
caesar that's a ridiculous comparison of
course um you know but um the i mean
caesar is also a great literary man you
know right he writes the best prose of
his age um he [ __ ] right um you know
like um a lot of amazing things about
caesar um but um
the most amazing thing in some ways
about caesar is what he does when he
wins the civil war right so there's this
incident after i forget the name of the
battle a battle in africa there's this
incident and the last senatorial force
in office is led by cato and cato is
like the bernie sanders of his time he's
like completely authentic everybody
respects cato everybody knows the cato
spirit is the spirit of the old republic
but the thing is the old republic you
know it's like senator palpatine said
the old republic doesn't work anymore
right you know and it just doesn't you
know and i'm sorry but it doesn't and
that will be the subject of my next
story um it just doesn't and um so
caesar you know
defeats you know the last blue state
army he's sort of the red state army and
then he defeats cato and cato does this
thing bernie sanders would never do this
uh he commits harakiri he actually cuts
his belly open with a [ __ ] sword
yeah right incredibly based right so you
have to respect cato but you know here's
the thing in cato's tent
which sees the captures is a big chest
full of letters from back home and the
thing is knowing about this prescription
thing
knowing about this prescription thing
you're like imagine you're like a rich
guy
in rome
you're not rich but imagine you were
rich you're in rome and you want to like
protect you're like villa frankly you
got a pretty nice villa right you know
one thing that you might think of doing
is writing a letter to both sides yeah
and being like hey
you know my friend cato you know i love
your policies you know your faith in the
old republic is like you know and then
you would be like caesar you know your
new ways you know right you know and
then you know the problem is that
basically if kato's tent gets captured
right there's your letter right caesar's
like you know
right you know
i'm not feeling too good about you right
now right and so caesar's guys you know
being very practical individuals are
like this is amazing
what do we do let's how do we you know
do we start with a do we start with z
like what do we do with these guys and
caesar being an imaginative strategic
visionary whose name would be
a synonym for the word king for um the
next uh 2000 years plus
um
is like oh here's what you do take this
chest
put it on a bunch of um
logs of wood pour olive oil all over it
and set it on fire
and these guys are like what the [ __ ]
and caesar's like you don't [ __ ] get
it we [ __ ] won right we're all our
people now right and so you know sort of
caesar's like genius in saying that
basically he's the monarch of like all
the [ __ ] people
right it's like you know
and here's what happens and you know
caesar
you know if you do this like
caesar could have taken a little more
care with his personal security okay so
if you're out there listening you know
you're probably the next american caesar
like you know
don't mess with that stuff all of my
audiences little caesars all you know
they're all literally eating a little
bit
right now you know you know so if you're
gonna do this like you know
you know just like be sensible you know
um um you know caesar was amazing but
his nephew octavian
who becomes augustus the next caesar
also amazing basically follows caesar's
position the whole conflict of the
orders
red state versus blue state
it's never heard from again it
disappears
imagine an america
in which the red versus blue
like distinction doesn't matter neither
side you know most people when they vote
in elections today they have a single
reason for why they want to vote it's
like [ __ ] persians versus italians
the persians vote because they want to
defend themselves against the italians
the italians vote because basically
they're like these persian [ __ ]
are going to do to us with what we did
to valerian
right beyond that nobody's like norman
rockwell nobody's like oh we need to
guide here are my ideas about nuclear
policy that like [ __ ] that that's all
gone it's just self-defense out there
and so if you can get to a point where
the self-defense is no longer needed you
should really be comfortable saying i'm
not gonna engage in this ridiculous
spectacle again that is the way the
romans felt after a few years of the
early roman empire the last roman empire
that actually tried to hold la hold like
elections in the street
like where people like
caligula and it was a [ __ ] joke and
everybody knew it was a joke and nobody
tried it again thereafter and so you
know basically
you know that's sort of the way
that
politics
ends
the way that politics ends is basically
people are like this is just a system
the system of the conflict of the orders
created caesar caesar couldn't come out
any other way than through the civil war
the next caesar will somehow come out of
the next president who's an fdr who's a
kennedy will somehow come out of an
american election that's the only way
you get to be president right right um
and they will just be like you know what
i just got elected president it says in
the constitution i just read the con i
read it i read on the bathroom i read a
couple times i had one of those long
difficult shits so i headed over again
it says that the president is a chief
executive of the executive branch to my
mind that's pretty clear
it says the supreme court can write
opinions and congress can pass laws
and um it is the president's um you know
understanding that he's here to execute
the supreme law of the land um
i is president
of course but i as president will um
[Music]
treat the opinions and the laws passed
by congress
with as much respect as they deserve
there's a great deal of expertise there
right i'll listen with great interest um
i am now
um so now i'm now sending the secret
service to the fed they're taking over
the fed we're going to fund an entirely
new government directly from the fed and
the power of the purse which is um and
is that constitutional yes it's
completely constitutional right in fact
you would describe this new monarchical
presidency as a constitutional
presidency and that's actually a
restoration of the real constitution to
put the chief executive in charge of
all the guys at bohemian grove kill you
or yeah unless you have let's okay okay
let's go into that yeah let's go into
that first of all it's not the guys in
bohemian grove
it's more the guys at the new york times
yeah it's the guys at harvard it's the
guys all day at the bohemian grove yeah
those are like old rich people who don't
matter you know like they're not you
know but you see they got there maybe by
mattering at a certain level they're not
the nexus
kennedy kennedy wanted to cover like a
monarch yeah kennedy kennedy and he kind
of did to some extent
but it's like the successors of like the
georgetown like world but so kenny they
take kennedy out in any case and yeah
sure nixon's remember i don't [ __ ]
know what happens with kennedy okay
let's say like i'm a kennedy agnostic
let's just guess he's taken out i'm a
kennedy agnostic in any case we have
this deep state so basically you have a
new president who comes in yeah this is
the now we got out of the past we spent
a while talking about the past yeah
actually let me talk a little bit more
about the past okay um
um most people don't know the name of
pompey p-o-m-p-e-y uh pompey was called
pompey the great he was kind of a
proto-caesar in some ways the reason
they called him pompey the great is that
he solved the big problem the roman
which was a problem with pirates right
uh rome and basically his day was it was
like mexico with [ __ ] drug lords you
had these like private organizations
pirate armies pirate kingdoms whatever
and rome gets all of its like food from
you know it's starting to get more and
more at least at the time of its food
from north africa it's got to get there
over the sea
right pirates can just rob that [ __ ] and
they do and it's becoming a problem and
the way that the republic deals with
pirates is just not [ __ ] working it's
like the way that like mexico deals with
drug lords whatever they're doing right
it's not working right you know um and
so
but rome basically has two forms of like
governance
it has
the civilian republican way of doing
things which is basically like a lot of
people with names like biggest dick is
written letters to each other and it has
the military way of doing things right
and the military way of doing things has
like been like testing its ass against
the gauls
you know for the last like 50 years
right and it's just like ruthlessly
completely effective it basically is
like comparing tesla to the department
of energy right or you know maybe spacex
to the united launch alliance which is a
good comparison because like the united
launch alliance is like private
companies too
but right they're not run like a startup
where spacex is and spacex is just like
we can do amazing [ __ ] for like 120th of
the money right you know 20 times faster
and so
the same thing happens and you know the
one of the key fun examples of this is
remember the obama healthcare signup
site yes where they were like they tried
to do with the dc way and they spent 500
million dollars or something and like
nothing worked and then they got a bunch
of people go and come in and do it the
silicon valley way and they like finish
it in a month in like you know for like
you know 75 cents right you know it
wasn't that they all these people are
progressives right you know there's no
[ __ ] republicans on this team but
they're operating the silicon valley way
and the silicon valley way is a monarchy
all startups are monarchies all
companies are monarchies you know if you
drive a car it was built by a monarchy
if you watch a movie it was directed as
a monarchy if you go to a restaurant the
chef is a monarch right monarchs are
everywhere once you see monarchies are
everywhere once you see them because all
effective organizations operate as a
monarchy and this was also true of the
roman military structure and so what
they do is they basically take this guy
pompey and at the time rome was such a
healthy place that to be a politician
you had to go and serve in the army so
pompey has political ambitions uh but
he's also a military guy
and um
this is like the destruction of rome in
the late imperial days the separation
between bureaucrats and military guys um
and in other words the state department
versus dod um and pompey basically
they they take this guy pompey i'm not
really sure why they chose him
um i'm not an expert as you can tell i'm
like a generalist and i don't know why
they chose them the senate is like okay
we're gonna do this military way
we're going to say pompey
you have absolute command you have like
ceo level control of the whole [ __ ]
mediterranean
anything that involves the sea
you can do get rid of the [ __ ]
pirates right and pompey
is like
okay
and without any computers without any
internet without any telephones without
any typewriters without any guns with
any of this [ __ ] in three months he
builds a [ __ ] fleet and basically
clears the mediterranean of pirates
right and
[ __ ] in rome are just like
[ __ ] because what they've seen is that a
completely different way
of running a railroad
where it's way the [ __ ] better right
than the one that they're all used to
that they're all invested in that's like
all basically the normal way of doing
everything so it's really about the
person right it's about the person and
the organization
when he when he looks at the uh when he
when he says let's burn the letters
they're all our people let's retire he
has to make the right call caesar had a
choice to be another marius he basically
was like no i'm going to be purple
because i'm going to basically govern
you know you said before a monarchy was
some form of accountability yeah right
and so that vague that was that was
something that the romans never
developed and most systems never so the
accountable monarchy is something that
genuinely hasn't been done before and
he's in some way or is that your idea or
is your idea the monarchy monarchy or
the accountable monarchy my idea is like
anything but what we have now it's like
first of all you have to establish go
back to the basic thing oligarchy is
[ __ ] politics is [ __ ] which means
democracy is [ __ ] right you cannot
basically if you like draw a quadrant of
like people who believe america's
democracy people who believe it should
be a democracy right i'm in the corner
of it's not and it shouldn't but hitler
would be worse than what we have hitler
would be worse right okay right the
thing is um you know the trains would
probably you know work a little better
but other things would be worse i don't
think they're transferring killers like
marius right hitler is like morris he's
basically governing from one side and so
hitler is the enemy of the german
intelligentsia which happens to include
the german german jews right and then
because he's a you know he's a [ __ ]
idiot he's like the jedi it would be
hard to have a trump who's very vain and
and and petty and vindictive
because trump would have been like give
me the letters yeah yeah trump would
have been like give me the letter
trump's not like let's burn the letters
trump is like give me the letter so much
trump doesn't even get the the point of
giving me the letters because trump
doesn't even win the war you know your
point is so correct about there is
efficiency to a centralized thing but
the person is the one person yeah so the
person so basically there are two there
are two risks in basically there's just
like no alternatives it's still a
monarchy no no no no like compare
elizabeth the first to elizabeth ii you
can't right you know and elizabeth the
first is a real monarch elizabeth ii is
like a kardashian with a crown right
right so you know you basically um
if you basically are like okay how do
you get the next american monarch first
of all like
the only way that isn't totally [ __ ]
scary is like electing a constitutional
president and having this president
basically rebuild the executive branch
from scratch right there was some recent
writing about this plan that some like
trump associates have right of like
maybe if we can like fire bureaucrats
it'll never work and i'll tell you why
both by the way my parents and my
stepfather all worked in like the deep
state for a total of like 80 years right
the reason why is that if you're used to
operating the in the private sector
you're used to an org chart which runs
from the top down so it's like in like
you know
like the platonic ideal of a big company
that's run from the top down would be
any company run by elon musk and like
you know it doesn't matter what the
engine engineers fuel the engine
engineers it's like spacex think that
like you know um the rocket should use
they could think it should use hydrazine
elon thinks it should use methane
elon wins right it's a real [ __ ]
monarchy it operates from the top down
um
when something becomes a bureaucracy and
by the way government organizations can
operate this way the manhattan project
ran the same [ __ ] way spacex right
right
government organization united launch
alliance works the same way as the
department of energy private company
right you know and so
when you're a bureaucracy
everyone's job is a process
when you go to work as like the most
junior employee of the state department
your job is not to get something done
your job is to go through a process
um you have a boss the reason you have a
boss is not that your boss has like a
higher level mission to accomplish oh no
your boss is basically who you kept kick
exceptions up to if the process doesn't
handle something it has what we call in
computer science an exception your boss
has a decision to make
if it doesn't fit inside his process
which is broader he kicks it up
eventually it will land on the desk of
the president right who's making
decisions all day long but if you
replace the white house with a magic
eight ball
like no american would notice the
difference right right it's just like
you know i was rebuilding an executive
branch right so what fdr did to solve
this problem fdr was already uh you know
the executive branch at his time was
much much smaller and much much more
elite and much much more somewhat top
down he went around it he created all
these alphabet soup agencies he created
new agencies and it took him a lot of
time to take over like the army and the
state department he had four terms
yeah right right you know well three you
know three in a little bit three right
um and um but he was going to rule for
life right you know that's another thing
that you see with monarchs the only one
who actually retires is washington and
um you know the um do you think lincoln
would have been forever
who the [ __ ] perhaps um and uh there was
certainly no law barring him uh you know
and people passed that law after that
amendment yeah 25th or whatever after
fdr
uh kicks it right and um
so
basically
the idea that like oh what's wrong with
this organization is that it doesn't
listen to the president
is sort of true enough but it doesn't
capture the sort of real need to like
completely restructure these
organizations if you look at for example
state the state department's 30 000
employees are some of the most elite
people in the world it's hard to get
those jobs uh you have to pass it's one
of the last you know one of the great
reforms that created the deep state was
like competitive examinations for like
government offices right that created
the meritocracy carter did away with
most of them in 1980
and um the rest are sort of being done
away with now when people hear this and
say
uh when you say run like tesla company
it sounds what is the difference between
your ideal version of a monarchy and a
fascist state um the ideal the
difference between the ideal version of
the monarchy and the fascist state is
two things one is that fascism is again
like marius and sola fascism basically
is sort of an imperfect monarchy and
that it's sort of the victory of kind of
one faction in a civil war the fascists
who sort of came to power whether
they're in italy spain germany or
whatever are sort of always coming to
power against the like mariuses
of their day right they're always you
know they're virulent and they're
fighting against like virulent
bolshevism that guys like and sort of
neither of those things exist today
which is sort of very very good like
people like compare oh there was street
violence in 2016 and also in like you
know 1932 i'm like in 1932 like five
people a day are getting stabbed to
death in berlin right you know and like
the communists are giving as good as
they get right right you know it's just
crazy and so you have all of this at
that in that era you have all of this
kind of locked up potential for violence
in the society because full of people
have gone through world war [ __ ] one
right right you know these people just
like kill you as soon as look at you
after you've been in the treasures for
like a [ __ ] week you have no respect
for life is there part of yeah
is there a country where you see an
example of this a better example so a
better you know singapore is a good
example of like you know singapore is a
multi-ethnic country right it has it
doesn't have persons and i italians but
it has asian it has indians and chinese
um and um you know basically
actually lee kuan yew comes to power you
know the the caesar of singapore comes
to power in a very similar way as
original caesar the ruling party of
singapore is still called the people's
action party it was like this like
violent anti-colonialist basically
quasi-communist party and basically it
puts forth this guy lee kuan yew who
becomes like establishes like william
gibson famously called singapore
disneyland with the death penalty right
um you know i like the disneyland part
um you know there are definitely ways in
which
singapore could be like more fun but you
can certainly walk around in any part of
singapore at any time of day or night
try that in l.a you know and um
don't actually but
um the kids out there certainly don't
try this at home don't try it
don't try it in san francisco either um
you know you might be able to get away
in it with it in channel right you know
and yeah um
the
in any case gotta do this callbacks do
you think that uh so
can i let me finish answering your
question for a second so that sense of
basically
like i'm carriage sort of all the libs
and even the cons out there like you
know conservatives kind of love fdr
right you know conservatives love the
kennedys right don't think in terms of
hitler think about fdr in the kennedys
right that's your sort of first point
like basically and and and you know if
you have to choose
honestly if you have to choose between
a dictator who's on the side of the
aristocracy and a dictator who's on the
side of the middle classes
it's a really [ __ ] hard choice but i
as a born aristocrat i'm going to choose
the blue caesar just because
you know
when
a populist movement becomes
anti-aristocratic
people are really right to notice that
like trump's voter base is the same as
hitler's voter base right you know
they're really correct to notice that
the wages
i like how we've we've oscillated yeah
i'm just making so many different people
no i love it yeah yeah yeah i'm not
trying to do this i'm sorry
it's just a fact right it doesn't mean
that trump is hitler right you know
hitler would [ __ ] laugh at trump
right you know all right and and the um
um
you know um
so are you all in for desantis then
because he's yale
you know
florida's fun
he's so you know it has problems the
thing that's the thing that's nice about
the thing that i really love about trump
is that he breaks the frame i don't sort
of feel desantis like no santa's has no
interest in breaking the frame yeah and
i said that's right and and i can't get
a hot on for him you know i mean you
know and and so that's the sort of the
genius a lot of the guys that you advise
their campaigns or
unofficially because i don't know what
you do but i am not i have no role i'm
not a player right okay so so so people
listen to you
sometimes sometimes uh you know um you
know the um um
but it really mostly just because i'm
funny you know
and what do you think a guy like peter
thiel's interested in politics is do you
think he's a is it from a business
perspective no absolutely not absolutely
not absolutely not absolutely not um you
know and and this is true of almost like
there's no one who wants everyone's
interest whether you're george soros or
peter thiel is not from a mercenary
perspective right you know once you have
billions of dollars like another billion
or two who can't [ __ ] matter like you
know the only thing that you can buy
with your money at that level is power
and the only thing that you're
interested in using power for is to make
a world that you believe in those all of
these people are completely [ __ ]
sincere you know and um and it really
that's the scary that's the scary thing
that's right right you know and
basically they're all completely [ __ ]
sincere you know and and so you know
when you get to basically sort of
constructing your kind of new monarchy
the first question you've got three
questions
number one is this person
capable
you know which unfortunately in the case
of trump is a no again
he's just he's not he's underpromoted
it's like the opposite of like
parkinson's law or the peter principal
like he needs to prove he needs to
realize that he's a great american
donald if you're out here listening
you're a great american
you should you should run in 2024 you
should win you should become the
chairman of the board and you should
hire a chief of staff you should be like
george washington right you should hire
a chief of staff who's like alexander
hamilton and basically do a lot of photo
ops play a lot of golf say a lot of
funny things on tv and on twitter um you
know obviously they'll give it back to
you
and um that's what you should do you
should be you don't try to be something
else don't try to be alexander hamilton
don't assume that your [ __ ]
son-in-law as alexander [ __ ] hamilton
got elon musk
you know you really think elon musk
would be this guy he might like he could
you know you don't have to be an
american you know okay he's an
african-american you know but the thing
is that like you yes you don't my worry
about him is he seemed he loves the
limelight he's a little bit yeah he
loves alarms
he loves the limelight a little much
yeah you know basically okay get elon
musk but 20 years younger you know get
the guy who's going to be elon musk that
nobody's heard of easy to find you could
probably ask elon musk and he tells you
when i was doing shows final question
when i was doing shows in palo alto i
was in san jose and i'm walking around
palo alto if i'm walking around with you
is it like
you could throw a stone and hit a
[ __ ] person who could do this [ __ ]
job yeah i could buy you know i couldn't
give you a list of 100 people i could
email you like 10 people and get a list
of 100 people who could do this but how
when you are in those in those in the
old world your old tech
world yeah um
is it a friendly reception is it like uh
is it like a mystique is it like that's
crazy how how you know honestly one of
the things that i try to do as a writer
that i recommend to anyone who's in the
entertainment industry is to basically
not consume any content that's about
myself right that's a good idea i
actually have there was this like vanity
fair article on the new right uh i
haven't read it right jeff bezos like
tweeted it i haven't read it right you
know and i'm not gonna read it sorry
james uh you know and and
like the uh like um um you know yeah
like so actually i kind of don't know
and i kind of don't care you know the
reason i started blogging back in 2007
was like this is what i believe i don't
care what other people believe this is
what i believe to be true i probably
made some mistakes um i think you know
i'm famous for being a little too like
coveted crackdown happy i'm convinced
that this is because i was betting on
kovid um
and you know so i've made my errors you
know
over time that's one of them
um
but yeah the the like the approach of
just saying what i believe is just one
that i recommend to everyone but like
before even even like before you like
read my [ __ ] like you know just like
do that thing i i talked about with the
islanders yeah like basically stop being
a sports fan right like it's like sports
fan politics yeah just like it's
pornography that's right it's [ __ ]
the pornography of power if you want
real you know if you want real sex give
up porn that's right start by giving up
porn yes completely serious about this
that's it and if you want real power
power that matters power that like you
know makes this country like what it
should be for like [ __ ] red state and
you know blue state and black and white
and green and purple and all [ __ ]
people in this country including even
the [ __ ] zombies down on skid row if
you want to basically make this the
country that this should be for everyone
just like turn off your [ __ ] politics
turn off the culture war and basically
just start thinking about how the
[ __ ] government should work i got two
words for you before we get out of here
and you don't even have to respond but
in my head
after everything you've just said
i got to be honest with you i think we
could do a lot worse
caitlyn
jenner
thank you very much thank you what subs
uh
subscribe that's gray with an a the
american way great mirror curtis jarvin
thank you so much we really appreciate
you coming home thank you brother huge
pleasure tim thank you buddy